As if I'm doing a fricking startin' scene screen.
Who do you take me for, huh?
Who do you take me for, a professional streamer, me, start loadin' startin' streams?
I've no idea how low this game is gonna be.
We'll find out in a minute.
I may need to lower the settings as well.
Hang on, I think this is a bit too cumbersome.
Speaking of busting, ehm, there we go.
No.
I'm done.
Johnny, please read the brainworms' marrows from half a day ago and begging and tapping
forward until I hear an answer for them.
Riefling.
I don't know what's eatin' you up.
I don't know what's happenin'.
I've been havin' brainworms all night and it hurts a lot and I can't get rid of them.
Can you tell me you love me and that you like the things I make for you?
I'm not a second fiddle riefling.
I don't know what that means.
Are you the riefling that was upset I reacted to that song?
Riefling?
I don't know what's goin' on.
What's changed?
What happened?
Of course I love you, Riefling.
What?
Yeah, seeing you reply to that riefling and hearing the song on stream hurts.
The AI song?
Yeah.
I don't know what I did or said to it.
I mean, I don't normally reply on Twitter, I've been trying to do it a bit more.
So I'm trying to collect my thoughts in terms of what I've done recently that would be bad.
I thought we were done really good.
You're not the stream riefling, although I'm sorry I requested a certain stream or video.
I'm not trying to make an excuse so I was high at the time.
Someone says, I thought you didn't want AI content.
No, I personally will not monetize AI content.
If you make AI art of me, I'm not gonna stick it on YouTube, hopefully.
Is mommy low?
No, sorry, I'm looking away from the microphone to read the thingies.
I'm just trying to figure out what I've done wrong.
I don't want anyone feeling bad when they watch me, you know?
Is it the latest drama?
Just ignore the brain one.
What's the latest drama?
Oh god, is it a drama?
I thought the drama was found, though.
Which turned out to be a nothing bowl, nothing burger.
Is it a drama I don't know about?
Does someone want to give me a heads up and wash my face?
Did I miss something?
Shibirate!
Oh my god, did you enjoy the...
Some fresh, needy drama at the end of the year.
I don't know what that means.
Hi, here I'm.
Did you enjoy your Elden Ring?
Oops.
I think the brain worms ate that refund.
I'm just trying to think what I've done wrong recently and I don't really...
Okay, I love you.
Thanks, mommy.
I don't know what I've done wrong recently.
Hi, here I'm.
You're gonna get a bit of deja vu.
I've been in the sleaze before.
Hire on the streets and it's out of my time to go.
We are gonna play Titanfall 2 campaign just as a...
Oh god, that's loud.
Just as a warning, warning question mark.
I have played Titanfall 2 before, the campaign.
Round two, yee.
And just to warn you, I am completely skipping the optional map.
I didn't realise the fights weren't even necessary.
So it's getting completely skipped.
So yeah, so I hope you enjoyed the Elden Ring.
Gorilla.
Hope you're doing well on my birthday.
Happy birthday!
As long as you don't have my little pony profile picture.
Happy birthday.
That's Matt Mercer?
That's McCree?
That doesn't sound like McCree to me.
I'm gonna go for the world record and the...
I fuck know.
McCree on stream.
During this era, he was every white guy male protagonist.
Doesn't he play Dungeons & Dragons on YouTube now?
Cinematic.
He's an attack and Titan as well?
He's a dungeon master.
He's Jotaro and Jojo as well?
How is his voice getting any rest?
What the fuck?
Who's McCree? I think he means Coleslaw.
Casserole!
I saw Titanfall move my butt here as well.
Aw, thanks.
Yeah.
J. Cooper.
Congrats if your name's Cooper.
Let's see how much I can remember of this.
Ooh.
That was a good one.
Are we fucking a giant robot?
Call me, call me Freddy cos we five knights in this robot.
That's not even a sentence structure.
Good try though. Nice attempt.
Ditch the Black Ops 6 beta.
Oh my god! I saw in Black Ops 6, apparently you can grab people from behind and talk to them.
I'm R-warding all of yous in Black Ops 6.
From what I've seen from the beta?
I can grab you from behind and talk to you in-game.
Do you understand?
I can literally hump you.
Congrats if your name's Cooper.
First, let us put on the, uh...
What sponsor of sales?
Oh, hell.
Shit must have power-cycled the simpods this month.
Oh my god. Is that a Kiwi, bro?
Bro, it's a Kiwi.
Bro.
My god, what sensitivity are we looking at?
We're a bit sensitive.
I mean, I, yes, the controls are fine.
Up is up and down is down.
You already do that one.
Drops weapon. Oh no, mommy got me.
You could already do that.
I'll see how it is.
If it's well received, we might play it.
It's bloody expensive.
Jesus!
All right, okay.
Okay, now I've just got here.
Right.
How fast?
Is this fast?
I don't know if this is too fast for me.
I'm analizing, I'm analizing.
Backup six is going to include an ex ghost game pass.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Regarding the drama, sometimes you can do nothing wrong
and we viewers will get in our own heads.
It's happened to me a few times with the other blue girls.
But I realized I was the problem, so don't worry about it, mama.
Well, thank you for the super chat, Sarah.
I was trying to think what I did wrong.
I was like, is it the shortest stream?
But it's like, I've kind of said why I did shorter streams
because I'm thinking my Bulbert, you know?
Oh god, my model is too bright.
Hold on, let's take the reactive model off.
Real!
I'm going to whisper all up in your ear.
I'm going to be very ink from a boy.
Oh, it's a spitfire.
He's my best weapon.
Oh.
I was going to say, I was like, why can't I shoot?
I thought the whole point of this game was to shoot.
Thank you, Stashfur again.
Got an embalm.
Nope, can't be bothered.
Let's go over here.
I want to get NBT because BT is refling and BFling is safe.
Oh, no.
Right, fuck it, let's just go.
I can't remember what I'm supposed to do.
What am I to do?
Am I to shoot him?
Oh shit, I guess I'm to shoot him.
Whoopsie.
Yeah, that's right, you can't need ease.
Hold on a minute, I need to roll before I get you.
Oh shit, my accuracy.
I'm trying to get through this.
Stop running.
I'm trying to get it through it because I don't want to run out of time.
But my accuracy is so ass.
Did I finish?
I don't know.
Oh, there you go.
New best time on my note, sure, whatever.
Oh, gorgeous.
We got 15 targets.
Average speed 20 kilometers.
Wait, you don't see the username on the mirrors?
I logged in with my name thinking you could see him.
No, I don't see.
You would have to say no.
Oh, it doesn't show me shebees.
Even though she's...
Oh, because I'm not in steam.
This would have shown me shebees.
Man.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Where'd you from behind?
I'm hoppin' you.
I'm hoppin' you when I grab you from behind.
Am I to go again?
Oh, don't make me go again.
Yes, I'm all done.
Yes, I'm ready.
Thank you, chair.
Thank you, internet basil fail.
I just want to grab you in game in Black Ops 6.
I just want to grab you from behind and be like,
hey, little reflin', you sure do look very vulnerable.
Is that a pistol in my pocket?
Or am I just excited to see you, you know?
Is that a fairness in your pocket?
Or are you just really happy to be grabbed from behind?
Beat me!
Reflee!
I'm trying to rhyme it.
One we didn't have to steal from the IMC.
Go ahead, rifleman.
Go on your first take.
Call and press Vector.
Vector for Vilt.
And then the babies.
Alright rifleman.
Sounds like it's about to hit the fan.
I know.
And now don't make me pull out mummy ass.
That's what I imagined.
Oh my god, I should do a really cruel audio like that.
Oh my god, and then you have to plead with me
not to pull out until I'm satisfied.
There's custom lobbies in Black Ops 6 of members.
I used to play tempo too, but no one would play with me.
External drive collecting doors.
Oh, this is sad though.
I never played this game multiplayer.
I don't even know if it is multiplayer.
Well, if the servers are still up.
Thumbs up! Thumbs up!
Oh my god, thumbs up emoji.
Cooper.
Anyone here call Cooper for no particular reason?
Congrats have some.
Right, I'm going to recommend a difficulty.
Let's do master difficulty.
Okay.
I like a challenge when I play my games personally.
Some people prefer just to go with the narration of the game.
Obviously the dev team do put a good bulk story behind it,
but I want a challenge when I play.
Yeah, master difficulty.
Still up just for hardcore gamers.
Titanfall multiplayer was still fun.
I'm sure I'm going to regret playing it.
I played the first one.
I missed a lot of things.
Such a pro game.
MLG pro.
Hold on, I'm just going to very quickly go with the volume.
Just a tiny bit.
Because I can't hear those at all.
Because of the volume difference.
Typical nation. Thank you for the tip.
I kind of want to build those ships in space.
Did you see me leak my Pokemon TCG card opening?
I picked the perfect box for my goth ass.
I'm one, you guys might guess which Pokemon card box I ordered.
We're going down.
Fuck hell.
Gengar.
Pick another creepy one.
Pick another creepy Pokemon.
It's been described as uncanny.
Jack!
Sorry, I just like scaring refunds.
If your name is actually that.
The Mimikyu one?
Yeah, it's Mimikyu.
I got a Mimikyu box.
I don't know.
Right, okay.
Sorry, I'm jumping in my chair right now.
And it's making my mouse do this.
But it's because I'm moving up and down in my chair.
Oh, I died to that the first time I played.
I remember now.
Oh my god, this is just what's that game called.
Warhammer.
No, hell divers knock off because look, these are robots.
How are we looking for audio settings?
Is it too loud?
Are we doing alright?
Are you friendly?
Oh, that actually scared me.
Oh my gosh.
That actually scared me.
Bruh, it's first thing in the morning.
Yeah, I just got fucking cock stomp.
Oh my god, that's so cool.
I don't know if it's just because I watched Mech Assault when I was younger,
but I have to admit a good Mech fighting game is so cool.
Baby, no.
War is hell strong, it is.
Oh my god, we have to watch him die in front of us.
I'm currently drinking my tea, so sorry for my tracking business.
Have you ever played Mech Warrior?
I have not.
Danger, danger, danger.
I can't believe the Kiwis are the baddie.
Oh wait, it sounds more South African.
South African.
I love her, we're still on top of Mummy.
Is it getting in the way?
I might have to take the reflins off with me if it's getting in the way.
I have not had a chance to play Armored Core.
Get away! Get off me!
Go and start fighting or something.
Is it like Thanatars from...
Oh, get off me!
BT, you saved me.
Oh my god, BT, are you still...
Oh my god, I'm limping, BT's limping.
BT, 7-2, 7-4.
Hi replaying, are you okay?
Hi baby.
What's wrong?
Oh my...
Hey captain, are you doing alright?
Are you feeling a wee bit rough?
Last emotion?
Are you doing alright son?
Nah, you're feeling a bit rougher.
Damn.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
What a dramatic fucking start to the game.
Logbook updated, escaped.
I like that we buried them.
As humans in our burying wills.
In the future everyone has a British-adjacent accent.
You're a McWizard, are you?
Free Titan though.
Hi BT.
Are you here to protect me, Refling?
New user found.
First name, Jack Cooper.
Hi.
Hi, Refling.
Initializing pilot combat systems.
Personal cloak, okay.
Ordinance, okay.
Firearms, okay.
Hi, Refling.
Are you okay?
Power level critical.
Scanning for sources.
Insides, not viable.
Not viable, not viable.
I think we have our objective, don't we, Refling?
Curry.
Insufficient power.
Hi.
The first words you ever spoke to me is power low.
Insufficient power.
Let me recharge your batteries then, Refling, huh?
You need your mummy meter filled?
I'll fill them up.
What gun are you?
I would like this...
Oh, that's a shotgun.
I'm not really fussed about that.
You can only have one of my primary at a time.
Protocol 3, protect Womi.
Fill your battery up.
I'll get you nice and strong.
As I said, I have played this game before,
so I do kind of know what's coming up.
I'm on legendary difficulty,
so if I do get any damage HP, that's perfectly natural.
That's what's going to happen.
Pilot Helmets Collected, one of two.
Half away.
Half away?
Thank you for becoming a member.
I'm so sorry I can't read that.
The one reason I mentioned some of the enders
are fantastic, EDA, my beloved.
We may have to play a MET game
that I've never played for the first time.
Armored Core seems to come up a lot,
so I think I'm going to be a cheeky wee shite
and do that.
I'm pretty sure I used to die here a lot,
because I don't have double jump yet.
Jump kit starts calibrating to new pilot.
Acquire the jump kit.
Oh, the wall!
Oh, thank goodness!
I was like, please don't die already.
That's embarrassing.
That's genuinely embarrassing.
Okay, let's try that again.
There is a mis-input.
Mis-input!
Calm the fuck down!
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Protocol one, being a pilot.
Protocol two, uphold the scuff.
Protocol three, protect mama.
I'm out of a beat.
I'm tempted to order an artwork
where you're somehow in the mech.
Right, okay, I'm going to say something really bad.
Like, really, really bad.
Okay, so there's artworks of D.Va's mech,
or animations of D.Va's mech
doing certain things, okay?
And I'm tempted to somehow order you as BT
in...
I'm tempted.
So, the artist that I'm currently working with
is doing some behind the scenes stuff
that I can't talk about yet,
until I can reveal it, obviously.
But I'm going to get her to swap to...
So, first artwork I need,
I'm going to do the cryo pod.
Because we played Halo!
Sorry, there was a grenade.
There was a grenade.
Because we played Halo,
I'm going to do the cryo pod.
It'll be rather emotional, so you better...
I think I'm going to put sensitive media tag on it
because I think it might upset you
with what I've got planned in mind.
Where am I going?
No one's no one.
Yeah, you ain't holding nothing off.
You ain't holding nothing off.
Right, okay.
No more grenades, okay, right.
Let's ride.
Then I'm going to get the anime watch long done
for that one scene.
That totally doesn't happen.
Bruh, someone drop the spitfire right now.
I'll hook two on that thing to get it.
Give me the spitfire.
Spitfire.
Target lost?
Or target locked?
I heard someone here.
Oh, there you are.
I found him.
Was he really obvious?
And I was just blind?
Oh, jeez, that scared me.
Sorry, that scared me.
Oh, good thing.
I'm just so MLG that I can sponge the bullets
even though we're playing on really difficult hard mode.
Oh, I'm about to run out of ammo.
Fine, I'll just need to pick up a new gun.
Who are you?
DMR.
Oh, this is a sniper.
I don't want a sniper.
Oh, come on.
I can't do anything with a sniper.
It's me, to be honest.
That's all I have to do.
Hi, I'm you here.
Hi, new.
I'm strongy.
Wait, no.
I'm supposed to say I'm dad.
Fuck.
But yes, the artist is currently doing some behind the scenes stuff,
so I can't ask her to do any of our stuff just yet.
But I believe by the end of September,
oh, this gun's actually really nice.
What's this gun called?
I would like to pick it up more, please.
Yeah, I like that rapid fire on it.
D, no, that was a sniper.
The recoil is a bit rough from a distance.
It looks like the bullet fall off as well as a rather...
Oh, that's why...
Oh, that's why they're offering me this gun right here.
Hold on.
Yeah, that's why they're offering me the sniper rifle right now.
Wait, they're surviving my bullets?
Oh, they're not!
Wait, there's robots and...
Am I the one who meant them?
If I was in Titanfall 2, they'd call me the spitfire.
That's why they gave me that gun,
but I would like the other one back because I like the...
Oh, I'm already out of fucking balls on it.
I don't even want a shotty.
I know exactly a static at the thought of having a shotgun.
I'm gonna have to be all up in it.
Here?
There's robots too.
We're getting closer to the battery.
Okay, they are giving me guns to pick from.
Are we picking the hemlock?
Sorry, that scared me.
It's only because I'm on legendary difficulty.
Oh, this is a three-bar-spire thing.
Here?
Okay, here.
You don't want the shawty, you just want the shawty,
like a melody in mind that I can't keep.
Rogue got me singing like...
Oh, no, no, no.
They're scaring me.
Can I get a flattler?
What's a flattler?
That's literally the gun I started with.
There it is.
Okay.
I got your...
I got your mummy batteries.
Spacey game.
The shawty wants the shawty.
Wait, yes.
I'm very excited about all the fun little artworks
I'm going to get some PM.
I just need to be patient,
because you know how it is with me daughters.
Daughters come first,
and we come together.
I was trying to get verified on BlueSight.
I feel bad for killing the wildlife.
It's not really their fault.
They just want a food.
Can I just...
What was I supposed to...
Wait, sorry.
Hold on a minute.
Giant refilling as BT
that also comes with bonus functions
on the Titanium is in control.
Okay.
We ink all over the place together.
Oh, I think I just spanked your bottle a little bit there.
Sorry.
Thank you, the bitty lord.
I never expected that someone like her would play Titanfall.
You're going to shit yourself when you look at my make-a-sult gameplay.
Okay.
Hi, refling.
You going to feel better if I give you this, darling?
There you go.
How'd you feel now?
You feel better?
Uh-huh.
Oh, careful.
Careful, careful, careful.
I'm okay, darling, but what about you?
Hi, BT.
Hi, refling.
Hi.
Yes, I can go get you another one.
Yeah, what do you need?
How'd I get there?
Okay, back on the ship.
Okay, you wait here and be super safe.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, you help me.
You talk me through things.
That's how you hold my hand through games.
You talk to me.
Why won't you talk to me?
But you did talk to me in-game.
Are you going to shit me?
Thank you, BT.
Hmm.
Voice analysis.
Don't worry, BT.
I'm not going anywhere.
Don't worry.
What am I supposed to go?
Ooh, not that way.
Whoa, whoa.
I mean, I'm not leaving you.
Refling, you're very literal sometimes, aren't you?
Very, very literal.
I think I did that way too-
Yeah, I did the-
Okay, let me try again.
Sorry, I did that way.
I hesitated.
I hesitated, okay?
Don't laugh.
I hesitated.
Am I going mental?
That's why you don't hesitate.
Can I make this jump?
Oh, goodness golly.
Why is gravity my biggest, like, issue in games?
It's just fucking gravity.
It's not even anything difficult.
It's just parkour.
This is why we're not playing Mirror's Edge
before anyone requests Mirror's Edge.
I'm not even kidding.
Like, fuck, we're getting a Mirror's Edge stream.
I can't even keep up with it.
Bruh, let me reload.
Hold on.
Let me reload.
Ref.
Where the fuck?
What?
You want to play Prince of Persia?
Isn't that not another parkour?
The rock.
Now I'm too high up.
Call me Japanese because I'm too high up.
I'm sorry.
That doesn't even make any sense.
I'm smoking the good kush because I'm too high up.
What the fuck are you saying?
How long did you serve with Captain?
Bruh.
See this gravity.
I'm going to shag it.
Bruh.
How about dying late at all?
That'd be terrifying.
It's your arch nemesis.
It literally is.
So I can see I'm supposed to go yellow, yellow, yellow.
Jump off this to get the gravity.
Jump.
And then.
All right.
Okay.
Well, of course the one time that I start seeing it out loud.
The laws of gravity.
I'm out of pizza.
Thank you, peppermint.
Thank you.
If you don't follow my Twitter.
I may have leaked.
I may have leaked my schedule.
Now my schedule is always subject to change,
but if you want to take a peek.
I actually plan like my stuff like months in advance.
Cause I just really like streaming.
I mean, hell on the fourth of May we're playing Lego.
Where is that?
I can see it.
But it's not dying.
Like we're literally playing Lego.
Star Wars Lego on the fourth of May.
That's like how far ahead I plan.
Cause obviously may the fourth be with you fourth of May.
I can hear someone down here.
Yes.
Where's that guy?
Oh, there you are.
Why are you hating?
Ow.
What just hurt me?
What just hurt me though?
Something just caught me.
I got my winky.
Ow, my winky already quitted.
Can I get a...
I only have 10 bullets.
I'm better going in with a freaking sniper rifle.
4 AM as well.
I've never had a good...
I can hear someone.
But I don't see anyone.
Someone's here.
Where are you?
So I can snipe your freaking head off.
Are you there?
I...
I heard...
Oh!
Am I going mental?
Yes!
I saw it.
I missed.
Come on!
I'm getting fucking edged.
Alright, let's see what we're dealing with.
I'll take this.
Hold on.
Much better, much better.
Ooh, spitfire?
No, not yet, not yet.
Getting edged in the...
No, no, don't go up there.
There we go.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Now you all want to come out.
But when I have a sniper rifle...
Ooh, we're so scared.
Thank you.
Press and activate clock.
Wait, the clock was like five seconds, BT.
You didn't warn me about that, darling.
The...
The clock was like two seconds.
BT, I think you maybe should have warned me about that.
Weed it.
Oh, my melee isn't on.
Hold on, I need to put melee on.
Uh, difficulty master, or yes, that's fine.
Controls, melee, melee, melee, melee, melee.
Me, me, me, me, melee!
Me, me, me, me, me, me!
Me, me, me, me, me, melee, me, melee, me, melee, I'm looking for melee!
Am I going mental?
Crouch, sensitivity, ADS, response curve, dazzling, invertebrate,
and thanks vote controls.
I said controller.
No, I want voice and keyboard.
Controls. What? That was a mental. Why am I on control? Yeah, but why is it on
controller? How do I get off controller? I'm not on a controller, nor is my
controller plugged in. Oh, right now. Under the tech? Under the tech. Ah! Why the
fuck would it be over here? Melee. Why would it? Huh? It doesn't register my mouse for?
Oh, there you go. Sure. Okay, there you go. It works. Okay, sorry, that's a mate.
She's been a true PC gamer. It has to go in my mouse, or I can't do it. Like, I
will not melee for the entirety of the game if it is not on mouse for. BT? Who's that
boy? Uh-huh. Sarah Briggs. It's getting a bit hot in here. It's getting a wee bit hot
in this ship. I'll tell you that much. Fuckin' hell. I feel like I'm in Barcelona.
Why is that fucking steaming up in here? Man, let's climb to the vents. Oh, wee bit of a
barbecue. Oh, my little toesies are getting toasty. Melee. Wait, how'd you say it?
I'm not saying Melee wrong, right? Oh, yeah. BT, you'll never guess what I've found for you,
buddy. BT ignored again. I'm so sorry. I'm like Melee. No, you're saying it fine.
Melee? I'm still saying Melee. Any Melee? Whoa. Are we done? Okay, we're done. Oh, BT,
I've got a surprise for you. Mummy's got a treaty, okay? I saw that helmet. Oh, no, no, I didn't
expect to go on it. One day, I will play a game where I don't die to gravity. Today is not that
day, though. And that's okay. Are you? Oh, right, I have a double jump. Thank you.
By what? I only see drones. Oh, they see me. I didn't realize they saw my location.
Where did the drones go? BT? Oh, daddy. I can't put it in you yet.
I feel very, I feel very baby when you're like this, Reiflin. I feel very baby. Like you're looking
after me. All yours. Yes. Hi. Oh, my God, Reiflin, you're fucking massive.
Uh, it's time. It's time. Well, pilot time. Hydration check.
Okay. Okay, okay, okay.
Ink to pilot. Got it.
I was green, though. Reiflin and Johnny Culls.
Are to resume special operation 217 with Major Anderson of the SRS.
I'm detecting incoming enemy forces. Okay, show time. Reinitializing critical systems.
Vortex shield online. The vortex shield catches incoming rounds and missiles. Release the button to
launch any captured objects back at the enemy. Okay, okay, okay.
I like that one. Bunk. I like like a magician like, oh,
press Q to paint multiple targets. The longer you hold down the button, the more locks you will
achieve. Okay, I likey. I likey. Bunk. Bunk. Oh, I'm slow.
Bunk. Oh, come on. This is so good.
Oh, yeah. Oh, no.
Are you sure about this?
Yes. Trust me. I trust you, Flynn. Right. Let's analyze what he does.
What's that? Get right. Get right.
Not bad, but I like how we have comms to each other.
I know this is your topic, which is obvious cause it's coming from me. Did you also listen to
some kinds of rock or metal songs? I don't normally listen to music. I'm sorry.
The vocal nation. I just listened to whatever happens to like, come on, but I don't like listen
to the radio. Have I gone the wrong way? I think I've gone the wrong way. Sorry. Sorry, I've gone
the wrong way. Yeah, she kind of just counter. Mummy actually getting skilled. No, like I don't
listen to the radio or like anything that's popular. And the nicest way, actually, when we hear
songs from Tick Tock, not even Lincoln Park. Is Lincoln Park the crawling in my skin one?
Crawling in my skin. I love them. Like I've heard of them, but like I couldn't tell you stuff.
Blood and rust.
Okay, sorry. I need to stop shaking my foot. That's me shaking my foot when I move like this
and it's moving my whole body. Yes, my foot is pressed against me.
Wait, why did you send that as a reasonable target? Oh, we have allies.
Oh, let's go. Hell yeah, it's BT.
Fuck no. Fuck no, I don't know when to give up. Oh, hold on a minute,
I need reload. This is embarrassing. Hold on. This is embarrassing. Hold on. Hold on.
I'm not ready yet. Hold on. Wait, let me. All right, let me get you first. Who next?
Oh, interesting. Don't care. Don't care. Shield a little to the front. Don't care.
Walk a little to the sides. Don't care.
Tighten logs. Press V to burst core. My ultimate.
Okay, press vector for my ultimate. Did you come from? Come on then.
Show me what I'm working with. You pussy.
What form?
Custom animation for death.
Okay. Hold on, let me reload. Pardon my French, but fuck them up. Light them up, pilots.
I didn't exactly get much on them. God, this guy is slippery.
And something's shooting at me, but I can't see it. I think it's other than him.
I'm gonna wish you were someone else.
He's on fire.
You're welcome. Yeah. Oh, I love unlocking new weapons.
New tired loader. Come on. Is this the Gatlin? Give me the Gatlin. Give me the Gatlin.
So now we no longer go... We go... Somebody's in love.
Adoration. Attraction. Devotion. I've not got the sword tighten unlocked yet.
I just died with it.
Are you playing you love me? You admit you love me?
You're 50% in love. I must win my love. See, everyone thinks titan falls a mech game? No,
it's a game where I must prove my love to you. This is a dating simulator. I don't care what
anyone says. This is literally a dating simulator. Right, so that's shield. Then what's my Q? No lock.
That looks like a lock to me.
Oh my god, I love it. Ultimate time.
Oh, this is such a good Q. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it.
I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it.
No, the Gatlin's a bit... Oh my gosh, I'm gonna have to get out of you, BT, but I love it.
Oh, it's sniping, get away.
It's a rom-com. It literally is. Right, am I supposed to get out of you? I think I'm. How
did I get out again? I don't know how to get out. Disembark, BT. Oh god, I don't know how to get out,
though. I forgot. How did I get out? What button? Nope, not that, whatever that was. Don't do that.
Um, tab? Caps lock? Shift? No, shift is zoom. Tangle, Y, U, I, O, P, L, K, J, H, G, M, N, B, V, C.
What is it? Hold E. Oh, there we go. We got out of there. Oh, I'm burning.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry. Oh my god, I'm so sorry. Did I do the fight again?
I'm so sorry. Where am I to go? How am I to get up?
I assumed to. Okay, definitely over here. Dumbass. Okay, let me get up. Let me get up. That was
embarrassing. I'm sorry, that was genuinely embarrassing. I completely forgot the whole point
is BT can stand in it and it's corrosive to my human body. Sorry about that, old chaps.
Oh, I didn't even know you could get up here.
Oh, literally the announcement in the background says requirement of wearing a hazmat suit at
all times. Where are you? A caber, a creeper. Did I go down or did I go along?
I go along. Okay. I'm sure there's probably like a helmet in that room or something and I've
just walked past it, but hey, oh, I'm gonna need to pick up someone's gun because I'm a bit of ammo.
Hold on. Right, don't open that gate. Yeah, I've not got a gun. Hold on.
Right, here we go. Now you can open the gate. Now I give you permission to open that gate.
BT is controlled by chat when you're gone. Oh, dude, how cute. I want to play. I wish there was
games like, I know we did stream sniping, but I wish there was also games where you could like
make stuff happen and like help me in my game. You know how like some...
Hi, baby. I think we're okay. Well, let's activate this.
Okay, please be careful, BT.
Like crowd control, like remontage and twist. I don't know what happened in
remontage and twist if I couldn't. Okay, yes. I can do this.
Split up. It sends risky, baby.
I need my BT. I need my Weflin. You got it, darling.
BT, you do the same. Copy that, Violet.
Firestar Wildcard. Sorry, that's the exact thing. I can hear the radiation noise. Yeah, I...
What do you have here, my love? Do you remember?
Can I go in the war? That's okay. That's okay to me. That's all.
Oh, shit. I should have probably expected some sort of jump. Who was that guy?
Narcotics user. Narcotics class. I'm going to Harbass. Narcotics cow.
Okay, what are you? What are you? No, why do you keep giving me snipers? Give me ammo.
Just give me ammo.
Cane, you're a bad man. I'm coming for you, Cane.
Oh, shit. That's what I'm saying. They didn't give me ammo.
Everything is snipers. A wheel needs a sniper.
Everything. K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar, K-bar.
I get it. There's snipers in the game. I have a terrible absolutely horrific
Factoid though. I didn't like Cavers. I didn't like snipers. Sorry. I've not got that. I've not got the accuracy for it
No, you do not see oh, it's me
I was like, how can you see some moving in the pipes that doesn't make sense. I am the pipes
She missed the Spitfire. Oh
Hi gang and give me Spitfire. Well, I got ammo at least
Get out of here
Get out right here. All right, I'll deal with this. Oh, no, I mean
Am I supposed to talk to I'm so sorry, I think I'm supposed to talk to that guy. Hey, how's your squad holding up? Hi, sorry
Oh, dear. You had better days. No, I'm not to talk to you
What you got a
Ball no, maybe not. Hi Robert. No, you don't want to talk. No talk to me
Talk to me. Why won't you talk to me?
Am I missing something?
See you you're next
I'm all isn't it the keeper is the game's equivalent of the 50 caliber
Take that take mummies foot in your back. Oh
She's you didn't see them right there
Right spitfire surely wait was that spitfire? No
Oh
Right, let's get row
Oh my god, there's so much I
Don't think I'm supposed to go over there. There's like far too many to deal with right now
Am I good mental that seems like a lot for a little old me. I don't know
Oh
God they take all they pack a punch as well like I know they're no human
Well, let's see if I can jump start this AI to tell it to stop spawning
One I didn't see you to knock off give me BT. I demand refling at once
Get me replaying I
Don't ask for much in this world
You'll give me my hundred percent love arc with re-sling right now. Oh
No, I can't be ours come for the head. Whoa. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. I'm
I'm not going for the helmet is what I meant to say. I feel like I've been walking for days
No, I'll be okay. I'm coming
Okay, I pulled the mission got it I pulled the mission
Was there not an enemy behind you actual schizophrenia kicking in oh, I didn't die. That scared me
Come on show me BT
Show me BT, I've never fucking played this game harder in my life until I get BT
I knew I could hear them
How many ammo I've got 200 I'm fine for now
Something's shooting at me up there. Oh
Oh
Come on that was a headshot buddy you should have kept peeking
Cane you're next for even separating me from them
Those who separate me will perish
In one way or another
My name is Johnny cuddles, and I will have my revenge
Oh
Sorry, there's a machine in the background as well a to dale
Mummy's fighting the high table free the reflins honestly for any ammunition. I'm getting a wee bit low on munitions
I
Think it's a 30 hydration check
Hydration hydration hydration. What's the bet death count none? I've literally not died in game even though I'm on master difficulty
Um gravity copium surely isn't my worst thing
You can say that you to be careful BT
Hmm. Thank you very laur for becoming a member. Thank you for the support. I hope you enjoy
No, I'm not to go in the pipe
Do not go inside the whole even if it's really in Tyson and you think that's what you're supposed to do
Why is against the dark? Let me climb this pipe
I
Didn't I'm supposed to go around
Jump up. Oh, I'm supposed to go around. Okay
Okay, oh don't do that
Following the laws of
Revers to that sounds great. Oh
I said BT to the wall. I'm coming
Oh
My sir random gun up here what I'm not taking a gun that has literally two bullets
No, don't come down. Wait, where did I come from?
Did I come up or did I come down?
We did it we did it we're together long time no see
Oh, is that a compliment? Are you complimenting me?
I'm a calm. Oh, no, I just remembered this section of the game. I like goes on for so long
Stop stop, I don't want to be see please come here
I'm just remembered they don't stop. There's like these nuke drones that come as well
They have like like dogs all over their heads and stop
Just remember
Again, I'm gonna die. I'm so bad at the game. Just shit, please
I remember I remember I
Remember
Can hear them creeping around. Oh my god. Oh my god
Oh
Stop shit me. Oh
My god, I can't I can't I can't I can't
Okay
BT are you shouldn't anything darling? I really need your assistance right now
honey bun
sugar pump pump Lillian can please
Shoot something oh
I
Don't like this bar. I can't remember why I can't come over. I think we're closing the floodgates. Oh
Who I need to reload
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we're just in circles. We're doing really weird circles
Really weird circles, but that's okay
That's why we're doing circles because they keep coming and I don't stop coming and they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming
And I don't stop coming and I don't stop coming and I don't stop coming and I don't stop coming and I don't stop coming
Am I safe here?
Oh, I'm not safe here. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, but maybe see
Quick I was like, oh, it might be safe up on this page
Bra, I'm trying to hate somewhere. It can't reach me leave me alone
But oh my god, it's so coming. It's so quick
It's so quick. Oh
My god, I'm out of ammo. Oh, who thought this? Oh
Goodness me. Oh good. Oh my face. It's getting incinerated
I'm not picking up a sniper rifle. You have to give me a gun game. Oh
My god, you have to give me a gun
No, no like that. Oh, come on
He has anything
Oh my god
Oh
I use meals they're everywhere
90% come on
Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on
I was a bit preemptive for that. There's I
Don't even know what the grenade button is. I'm spamming G but it's not that. Oh, it's cute
I'm out of everything, please
Thank you, my love. Oh my god, please come get me pick me up
I want to be so badly right now. How do I get to you? Can I just jump this? I'm off. I'm fucking jumping it
I'm so as I'm away. It's not my problem. Oh
Oh
Okay safety comfort love joy it's peace tranquility
Security mazl's hierarchy of needs
It's all okay now, it's all okay
We're gonna be okay. We did it
Daddy BT you want an alternative to our BT I can do that
Okay
You can go invisible. Oh, I forgot about that
Now go pour one out for all the ears that gotten don't listen to my streams loud
I don't know why you would do that. You silly giver. That's right. I'm victim shaming who goes there
Wait, how do you get allies but I didn't
I
Know let me call on the refunds right now. I know for a fact. They'll be a refund. I know that play this game
You're good
What's the G I don't know what G does
Leave me alone Kane leave me alone
I'm a donkey on edge
Right, let me get rid of his wee brute first
Oh take it like a good little enemy you are. Oh, that's right
Get right
Notty boy little teabag
Oh, I got praised by you
Well done, Ronnie. Oh reef link. Thank you. You know, it gets me where when I get it stop
Disembark and removes Kane's helmet from the radio. I know right hold E to disembark
Okay, let's grab it. Oh, I like a little tilt
Oh, we're on the inside
Mailing mercenary when their health becomes danger
Hi, daddy
Militia
Oh
He's dropping on the enemies I ain't dropping no if sir I
Just I just wanted a close-up. He got one. You got one. They all got a close-up. That is a really
There's a blooper reference to Lord of the Rings
And then Gandalf goes in front of the camera and goes no, no, I want to close up
He starts moving his hair to the side. Oh my god, I can't wait to watch the behind the scenes Lord
It could be a short cut to the run
I recommend we proceed. Oh, you're so big. Honestly. Look at you fucking hell
I'm like what one-third of you one-fourth, baby
How much maneuverability do you have
I did a big girl leap just to get in there. Jeez
Yes
I'm gonna trust that you'll also take over if I messed up
What is this place
What are we doing here darling
I
Good luck with that. So who's blitz
Okay
That's not very nice all is it
Oh
That feels like a war crane
That was like incinerate ammo. Oh, sorry, sorry dragon's breath the dragon's breath wink wink not against the Geneva Convention, by the way
And
I
Take BT shortcut to the rendezvous point
Can I just walk on you no I can I do have to attack you
Well, I wasn't sorry, right, what are you?
Oh sugar I'm hurting myself
Okay, I can hurt myself with my own stuff. This is definitely not the loadout for me
This is not the loadout for me if I can hurt myself with my own stuff
Okay, that didn't do anything. What does G do?
I'm hurting myself again
Right, sorry, I'm gonna end up killing myself. It's class. Excuse me real quick. Oh
I got environment only killed again
Why is it that's my biggest problem in video games freaking environmental care? No, I didn't die if you're not watching right now
No, I didn't die. I promise I
Promise I didn't die. You just misheard the stream. Okay
You just miss it go back to what you were doing if you're listening that work
Go back to your work. Make sure you get them emails signed off
Make sure you're saying love from reflin at the end. No, that's not how you do a business email. Sorry
Um
As pair my last email I require
When is the next bit coming down? I'm getting sniped by that as pair my last email
Is it I'm I being pranked?
Prank I'm John. I think they're pranking me. I swear if that comes down because I've sat there. I'm sat right, okay
I think I'm okay
Fucking nervous. I saw that. I think there's an enemy in here
Hmm turn the toggle on and you say it in a word. Whoa, I did not expect an enemy. I
Did not expect you at all
I do the game has
Incredibly fair. Oh, I'm I very much very very I'm appreciative of that
I'll show you who a real tone is
Whoa, where did you come from Titan locked you?
Gee wait, that was not what wanted. Is that what I wanted?
Hey, hey
Yeah, yeah dodge that bitch I do have an ultimate if I want to use it
Yeah
No, don't try and run away. You're on the wrong team. I don't care if you try pay for your mortgage
You're on the wrong team
Did I miss everything I think it did
Okay, we got one next next next next next hold on reloading
Okay, hold on
I
This game just ten out of ten experience. It's just fantastic. I can't get over it
Okay, I have my ultimate back something's shooting me. See you. You're absolutely toy and you're taking on my HP
That salvo core went like hot dogs down a hallway
Oh
Hey, I thought it was gonna only okay. I thought it was gonna only but it didn't use G to lock on quicker. Oh
You're saying little I'm sure I'm gonna use it for like five seconds
Curious and what are you flak and then G fly
Offers a shortcut
I need to have a BC don't know
I
Need my summer I fell me with her breath
It keeps me in his net
I don't know the words if you want to put the lyrics and chat I'll sing it then
Cargo lists do you even lift Brad? Do you even lift a master Wayne?
No, come on, I just
Please don't hurt
Be gentle I'm coming BT. Oh my god. I just freaking got you. Are they hurt in your back?
Help mommy mommy's coming
Suck it protecting you honestly fucking had to go away from you in the last one and I've already lost again hydration check
I'm coming I'm coming
I
Let's work for you. No, you've made a mistake. You've made a mother
Give him back and I'll go without a fight
Oh, I love the sound of the gun as well. It's got like the best on sounds like
Just sounds the best
Best on
Time to get you back. Did you forget to put quarters in the parking here?
You got me. Oh my god. You got report from me
Don't care
BT how do I get to you?
You must follow the pipes
No, I can't even talk to you
I can't even talk to you
Even though that was like a maybe a 45 degree acute angle just go for it. I'm going for it
Be careful pilot
Where do I go?
There's a gun offered to me here, but what's that called devotion?
I mean, that's a bloody good. That's pretty good name for us a bit of a cheeky devotion. Where am I to go? Oh
There's a hole in one of them like when you don't know what to do just go down the hole
Ah
Over qualified more like over
Dead
Right where we're going
Don't you dare
Don't you dare destroy my baby am I gonna get
Over penetrated by bullets
Thank you, thank you, right I I'm like 98. Yeah, this is the mission where you don't even have to fight
Like you can just keep going and obviously because I'm so MLG the bullets aren't even gonna grieve my skull
Cuz
literally
You do not have to do any of this fight and the first time I played this through
I was like doing all the fakes and I was like, why does this seem like it's going forever?
It seems like it's going forever because it is it is optional to muck about okay, and I'm just skipping it cuz
it's not even if it was paratips to the level sure
but
Literally, we just get thingy dover and over again
I'm doing something
Geez almost got fucking laminated
Almost became as flat as a freaking squid
Okay, that's not that way
Don't care. Oh, maybe a little bit here. I
Need to analyze what I'm to do
Okay, I think I'm okay
Invisibility good
It only lasts like a millisecond, you know
The hell are they building
Mass producing homes
They said we're gonna area we're gonna end homelessness. We've had enough
They are grass on a metal plate. I can't remember what the big baddie secret was behind it
I'm gonna get a couch put on my head and die. Aren't I?
Okay, close enough. Okay. No target dummy
Hold on easy easy take it easy take it easy
Oh
I see him. No. No, I see him. I think I'm gonna need to stay on the production line
Shit shit shit do not stay on the production line. Oh my god. Did you see the way my body dunked it down?
Right, don't stay on it get off it
Hello looks like you're out to rescue a kidnapped but that's exactly what I'm doing right now
They put dirt on the plate like that was the first that I hear you can have your your agriculture
As I said, I'm just skipping the section because they just infinite respawn and I'm no mucking about what infinite respawn
I'll blow them up they freaking scare the soul out of me
Sorry the robot height and the human height is very different
Why why why why so many I?
Assume this is what I'm supposed to go on I
Really hope this is what I'm supposed to go on cuz I
Didn't look ahead. I'm gonna be honest. I'm not to go left or it looks like I'm supposed to go this way
For safety reasons. I'm going this way because I don't know if I'm about to be tipped upside down
I look like it's something
I'm not very interested in music on this map is like wham-wham-wham-wham-wham-wham for the horns. Oh
Peace off ghost
I'm not a fan of those spider
Let's try that again shall we
I
Am I supposed to go yeah, if I got the wrong way am I supposed to be on the production thing?
I'm starting to think I'm supposed to be on the production thing
I've gone the wrong way I should have stayed on how
Hold on let me reload I went the wrong way. Let me reload
So I know it does tip it tips
What does it do?
See this is what I don't like about the map like I wish it was just linear, but it's not
So I need to jump back on it
The horns be hornin right now. Oh wait a minute. I'm supposed to jump on here
Yeah, I could hear you come in
I have curious it's just a spawn location. I'm just looking around just in case I'm missing a pivotal bull
Well, I mean this looks like it so bulls phone note
Mama doesn't like getting chased unless it's by us or something a little more furry
Aren't you hearing?
Thank you anonymous. No, I just get so worried of like oh my god. Are you supposed to be here half the time?
And all your profile pictures are very interesting. Am I reflin?
We have fucking sentries down and everything and the spiders are back. Oh, yeah, what's going on above me?
Wow, there's a lot of spitters behind me
Okay now this get me on it, please. I don't know where I'm going but take me to space take me to Mars
I'm just looking around but it looks like I'm supposed to be on this I
Hope I'm supposed to be on there
Okay, we're going down the guard real I can see the real here. It's like a it's just we're going on Disneyland, right? Okay?
We're doing a bit of Disney
That was a meat grinder
No with my luck
Sad down
Me grinder just like oh
You get applause for meat grinder good comment
I
Really love this level the level design is great this part. That's about to come up ten out of ten
It's just that section. It's like well, I'll fit the knee at the feet. I'm staying on it
Dedicated
Sure
I'm locked in no
This is messing with my head a little bit I can like claim on the mannequin. Ah, there you go. Okay another bit
Hey, okay, no
Right, sorry, this is really messing with my head right now. I'm trying I'm trying hold on
Right, let me enolize
I'm to get up there. How'd I get up there? I?
Don't know. I need to go back in order to go up
like
I don't like this all hold on
Okay, I need to get on top of this thing again
Looks like I do it from here
Okay, and then get back on top of the orange thing. Okay good progress progress and then
Yeah, I need to run over to this one
Okay, that's good, and I can claim this because it's just a sleeping claim
I
Right well
Maybe if you didn't make it so freakin awkward to get to the dome then we could do a fight a sequence a bit faster
You know exactly made it that easy. Have you had ash more like?
More like
You yeah, what source?
Ash more like
But I can't think of one thing right now
Okay, now that took me so long
Yes, so I never died once getting here. I feel sick bro. That was hard you tell her mommy exactly you got her nailed trash
Try yeah ash more like to rash
What am I to do?
I
Okay, thank you for the instructions because I wouldn't have known better otherwise
Can I have BT
What if you gave me BT right now
Tee he Tee he what if BT?
What if BT
Ash more like
Cinder
We know ashes dust yeah ash more like dust when by the time I'm through with her
She's gonna be worm food and dust and stuff
Ash more like smash her face in yeah
Loading scenario one two seven in dynamic simulation dome more like tit rash. Yeah, let's fortnight chuck to that
Well fortnight chuck to that
Ash more like trash I was right there
Can I have BT?
What if you gave wouldn't it be so cool if you gave me BT right now
Wouldn't that be so elite gamer of me god they give me platforms and everything
Wouldn't that be so amazing
Come on come on
Delivering militia test subjects I
Know you can't I know the beat
Oh
These real
They do test oh
My god, they like do test to like make their AI better and stuff
Double light machine going like I'm sorry
I guess this is
Yes, you can see that darlin
That's pretty natural that's pretty natural for me initiating I am see Reaper test program
Oh
God more what we looking at
Where they shouldn't I'm a human
It's not even it doesn't have a HP bar
Why me why me
No, don't don't do anymore
I'm not enjoying this test scenario
I'm trying to do core damage to okay, right one
I
Got an achievement called. I'm not locked in here with you. Is that a reference to that one movie?
You're locked in here with me and then he throws oil on the guy's face or something like that. I don't know what that movie was
Why destroy me
I
What comes out of those oh
Damn, that's actually pretty nice gun sound my gun go
Kappa
I'm getting scared brah only have one ally
I
Why would you
Oh
No darlin, I'm gonna need your help you need to come thingy
Think I
Am I safe
Am I safe can I get over here? Oh
My god, I'm safe. Oh
Okay, I'm out. I'm out. Oh my god. I thought that was like a big tree in there
Showing your aims in person. No, it's not spring and brain. Yeah, I
Thought that was all girl in there. Can you one be one in Titanfall I have
Games
Oh
Ash got a spanking
Ash more like can't complete her mission objective and thus gets no cash
Oh, no, I think I'm just remembered. Oh, no, no, no, no, do they keep
Do they keep coming in and out or am I making that up?
Brother per dog, I didn't know any better
Right you're scanning the terrain I'm scanning the terrain
I
This way whoa
God you're so jumpy you're so ready to jump off the mat
Above as above is so blue. No go away
There's no
There's no way I
See BT on my crosshair though, I don't see him but I see him on my crosshair
What is going on are they even fighting me are they can I just
Can I hit me I just uh, you know what's down there, I don't know I can't see it
I think it's one of these panels. Oh
My god, I can see you darling you're in the distance
Yes, yes, yes, yes
Right, I just run ahead. I just run ahead. I just run ahead. I just run ahead, right. Let's go. Let's go
Okay, shit. Oh, come on
Maybe
Maybe my baby
Okay, well, let's try that again. I had the right idea, but I had the right idea
Okay, I just misjudged it terribly right run and double jump and hit the surface
And then and and and up he's up he's up he's up he's oh
You don't have to tell me twice
Right hold on let's go on the good one. Let's go on the good one. You know what I'm here for
I press G to lock faster
Come on look look look look
Come on right one
You're so good
I'm not actually gonna use my all I'm gonna save it because I think there's the bird to be in fate
I'm not gonna chase you down. I'm doing shade apparently. Oh
What is this is that you did you do that?
Oh
Yeah, it's happening all right, let me replenish
This whole facility is falling apart
Come on, we may need to get on it or we're gonna be in trouble
Oh
It's it does everyone know this facility is falling apart or
I'm trying I
Don't know what I'm shooting out. I'm sure not everything I
Think there's like from the amount of green that surround I think this is the boss fight if I remember
Yeah, okay, let's go
She here
Have you ever thought of selling leaflings merches? Yeah
It takes time and I
Want us all to come out with it at the same time
I
Just need to get a date confirmed
Why are you in my asshole?
You don't want fuck it you want to be in my ass
Get off get off
Get off get off get off
Fuck you
I
Exit the facility
Let's go let's go let's go let's get the heck out of here cuz I don't trust it
Gooshie boo
I'm gonna need you to hurry as best as you can BT and we are big boy, but yeah, we flee markable plushie real answer
Yes, I
Spoke to the girls about it, but they weren't ready for it yet because it requires a down payment to produce
And they were in
You know obviously shame them here
We're gonna have to put a debt above your head type thing is not really the funnest thing ever
Obviously, they would keep 100% of the merchandise produced
But they have to put a down payment and it would be like hey everyone has to get we cheeky day on them
They weren't fussed for it yet, so I'm gonna ask them
Again and see what we're thinking and
I'm also
gonna ask the
If it seems like oh my god, yes, I forgot yes, yes, yes, yes, yes
Oh, I'm gonna be wise enough to be able to do this. I don't think I'm smart enough for this
I don't think I this one. I've always struggled with
No, my god a scratch and snow stoning which is happened
Wow, okay
Hello, I would like to give my lecture and today we are going to be talking about drugs and why cocaine gives people an ego
It's a very strange and unique phenomenon
That gives an artificial boost to ego when normally it cannot be created through
Socialization in any other context. Would anyone have any questions about this?
I'm ready to give my presentation on my drugs
I'm supposed to go up here
And
We'd give super munchies. Oh, let me be clear
They've been mean to the ball
I
Rather big
Can you repeat that part of the stuff we said all the thing yeah, you forgot
How'd I come down?
BT is this where you were born?
What is this place
I drew since you think
How many of the facilities these facilities are there in the eight standard months prior to operation brought sort
Or destroyed over 29 such installations
Take any full damage
Thank you crazy Jesse we have hydrated
I don't want to take fault. Can you see full damage in this game? I'm unsure
Okay, I'm going to BT and I hope these guys don't attack me
Hello
I'm detecting traces of a massive energy explosion throughout this facility
However, the ground the data does not detect the same in the other timeline
None of these remains match the genetic profile of major Anderson. He may still be alive
Uh, I can't remember
I don't think he is
I'm trying to remember but I can
You're chassis time to earn my keep
Okay
He's so big
Is that true? I was like something out of Pandora
I'm sure there's a dog in here that scared me last time
That like jump scares you
Where is it I know for a fact I'm about yeah, I knew it you little shit
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I knew it you scared me and I remembered the jump scare
Oh, yeah
Oh
It's grabbing onto his hand to get the helmet like oh
Oh dear, oh dear, oh dear
You freaked it all out. This isn't BT. I found Anderson
No BT
It's cold BT
Raiflin, I know you're a little old baby, but Raiflin come on. You can't even be saying that
Why did these grenades that show?
Okay, I'll take a that show
What is this?
Oh, it's c4
All right, look at my keyboard
I will analyze it. Okay. Here you go daddy. All yours
With the death of Anderson command of special operation 217 now transfers to you
Congratulations on your field promotion by the coober the following is anderson's mission briefing from commander sarah bridge
Okay
Major anderson two weeks ago. We intercepted imc comms. They found something on titan
A massive blast of energy was discharged at this location creating time distortion. Yeah, uh, I would see it
Looks like a big old blast the energy. I don't know about you, but something big happened here
This risk-mounted device we recovered during operation grizzly should protect you
We know the imc have contracted cuban blisk and his mercenaries to protect something critical there
So watch your back and anderson. You know how much I love writing death reports. So don't go alone
The srs is a team
That was sarcasm. She doesn't like writing death reports
Congrats on your promotion. Why thank you. It worked very hard for it
Recommend we locate anderson's risk-mounted device before proceeding. Okay. I guess I'll go
I didn't see a device on them though. You can see any device on anderson. It must be on the other half of his corpse
I have to reach in the security services building. I will provide access
Oh, is he gonna
Uh, yeah, no
It's gotta be an easier way, right?
Okay, see you on the other side darlin. Bye. Bye
Don't get kidnapped. I'm tired of you not having access to you anymore
I need full access
Oh, no the robots are asleep, but they wake up
Oh
No, no no, no no no no. This is creepy. Please
This is horrifically creepy. There's no way. I'm dying to this. Am I dying actually? Oh my god. They keep coming
No, just run they keep coming. I'm off. Bye. Bye
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. I completely forgot, but that I'm just running running running running running
Running, running, running, running, running, run.
Running, running, running, running, running.
Oh my God, this is so strange.
Yeah?
Oh my gosh.
Was Your  portraits gone?
All right, all right, all right,all right,all right,
all right, all right, all right, all right, all right,
all right.
I forgot about that four.
Completely.
God, it's the other half of Anderson on his wrist.
Oh, dear.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
That's like, how?
That's even worse.
That is so bad.
Average position you're left in
once I'm finished with you.
He wall hacked.
Right, what did I do?
Press N to time travel.
Okay.
Okay, if it's easier to just,
oh, please don't get it.
I can't even remember what I'm supposed to do.
Okay, okay.
It's coming back to me, kind of.
Should have been a kiddo.
Oh, my God, I like that it tells you
that there's like radio signals.
Okay, okay.
I can do this.
I'm not doing that.
I can do many things,
but that is where I draw the line.
I draw the line at those guys.
What's going on here?
Oh, it's the elevator shaft.
It's the elevator shaft.
Oh, yeah!
What happens now?
Oh, my God.
Oh, raid.
What am I raiding?
Oh, there's something after me.
Raiding, I'm raiding.
I'm raiding.
There's something after me.
I can hear it.
Oh, my God.
I'm cute.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Help step, pilot.
I'm stuck.
What is this?
No killing, am I killing you?
Like, I'm playing on master difficulty, okay?
Excuse me for not wanting to engage in every fight.
I get scared and nervous, okay?
I'm on my own.
I ain't trying to do this on myself.
I'd rather have a need for that, so...
Oh, no, not dealing with you.
I don't have to go this way.
Yeah.
What's this?
Bump, bump.
Well, I'm supposed to jump down and then go bump.
Okay, what's going on in here?
Let me see, let me see, let me see, let me see.
Let me enilize, let me enilize.
Decoding calibrating helmet.
Okay, okay, okay.
Anderson's over here.
Hi, Andy.
Congrats for your names.
Master difficulty easy.
No.
We took it.
This is the first time I've seen this game,
but I had very different ideas of what this story was.
This one's empty.
The arc must be somewhere else.
Anderson out.
The arc is not here.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, the arc is not here.
Checkpoint reached.
I saw this jump down, so that's supposed to be where I'm going.
Oh, it's even worse!
Oh, it's even worse, it's even worse, it's even worse.
It's even worse.
What's going on?
Fuck it's separate!
Everything's getting worse, it's getting worse.
I don't know what to expect when I'm running ahead.
Cause I'm running around.
Whoa.
Give me that.
What's that?
I can hear stuff.
No, I'm doing a map.
No map problem.
So there's no map problem.
It's not in my paycheck.
I'm out.
I'm too scared when I'm not in BT.
Like, I feel so overpowering BT,
but then I feel so squishy when I'm not in BT.
Nope.
I'm not doing parkour either.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my God, I don't have enough brain power to be doing this.
This is a bit too much for me.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God, I don't have the brain power for this.
I'm just so hard.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
That scared me.
I thought I was safe.
No, there's too many.
So I'm going back to the past.
There's too many.
There's unironically too many.
Why is there so many dogs?
In the facility?
No, don't start with the bots either.
I'm going to have to fucking pick the lesser of two evils.
Then he's start.
Oh, my God.
I don't know who to pick.
Give me the weapons.
Give me the weapons, please.
Just anything.
Oh, fuck it.
The dogs.
I picked the dogs.
I think there's less of them.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, am I okay?
Okay, there was less dogs.
See in the prison.
The prison has less enemies that I have to deal with.
What did I do?
I fucked up.
See, right.
Did I do something?
Right.
Okay.
Hmm.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Right.
I can do this.
Gravity is my friend.
I am smart.
I am wise.
I am so good at this game.
Bitch!
Right.
Again.
Let me try again.
Hold on a minute.
Now, hold on a minute.
We go off to a bad start, but that was me.
Okay.
Right.
One, two, run.
Jump.
Spawn.
See, it's simple.
Easy.
Simple.
No problems.
No issues.
No fuss.
No things.
We did it.
Easy peasy lemon peasy.
Right.
Let's see what I'm looking at.
Hmm.
Mm-hmm.
Ooh.
Ow.
The entire thing is a power grid.
One, two.
One.
Please let me in.
Cambly.
Okay.
And then a little 360.
I'm okay.
How did I do that?
How did I not die there?
I don't know how I did that.
I actually didn't get it though.
Who's your pilot?
Oh, well, he couldn't have died here
because his body's not here.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
That was Major Anderson's final recording.
His thing, bro?
Send a recon of this facility.
I may have a plan.
Meet me outside.
outside. Yes, please. I want my BT and there's something in my way.
Ooh, what are you? Oh my gosh, we're playing Fallout. It's a ghoul.
There's news. Oh yeah. No, that's, you can't do that, both. Leave me alone.
That's cheating. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Don't start scaring me now. This isn't a horror game.
This is a rom-com with some guns. Okay, it's a rom-com with some guns.
I recommend you meet me at the rings in order to scan me. Maybe at the rings. Time travel.
Hi.
BT, what are you fainting, darling? BT's not in this version of reality.
Can I come in? Please? Thank you. Let me deal with it.
Yeah.
Oh, BT can come with me. BT can come with me.
I love it. No. Oh, sorry, I was trying to use my shield. They've changed it. There's no shield.
There's no shield. There's no shield. They changed it. Hold on. Let me get rid of the big boys first.
Okay, fuck it. Hold on, hold on, hold on.
No lock, no lock. Right, let's get you.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
I'm to do what? Extend the bridge, fold weapon prototype? I don't know what that means.
Okay, right. Is this what I was supposed to do? Tighten load out.
God, just stunning. I'm sure it's good. Don't care. Don't care. Like, I like my rifle.
I have to get out of BT. I don't want to be out of BT. What do you do?
Oh my god, I like this hacking.
Scan it. Scan it. Oh, BT? Oh, don't do that to me. You scared me.
Okay, then open.
Wait, so what? We're running into it? Scan the arc at the center.
I don't recall. I don't remember. Are they fighting? Oh, no, they are fighting.
Did I die?
Did I die? Oh god, not gravity again.
Holy shit.
Oh, gosh. Oh, I messed up so badly. I am in so much trouble.
Can I grab you?
Percy.
This is what we came for, the arc?
We did it. Take that damn glove off. We ain't Michael Jackson here.
Okay, we did it. It's because like I'm familiar, but I'm like, I don't remember this.
I don't remember that happening. You broke reality.
The arc exploded during the test. It's the reason my timing is like,
remember that timing got out of the P-word and people were like, no, his music's so good.
I'm going to ignore that fact. And it was like, okay.
Damn, you can claim? What the fuck? When you claim me like a monkey.
Why did you do that? Let's hope.
Okay.
Okay. Yes. Can I go?
Reefland, let me ensave you.
Reefland, I just want to be insane. There's some nice and cozy I want.
You appear to be programmed to attack the control room.
I detect traces of poisonous chemicals within the fog.
What is in the fog? What is this fog?
Scanning. The ground fog is a toxic byproduct of the beacon power grid.
I recommend you embark when operating in hazardous conditions than one PPS.
You wouldn't let me ensane.
Okay, now I'm allowed to ensane. I'm happy again.
Press F1 for new alert. Nope.
Reestablish contact with him.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm here.
We're getting overrun by stalkers.
I recommend we eliminate these stalkers.
Yeah.
Okay, let's get rid of them on the wall first.
I can stand on them.
Would you like to be stood on?
Yeah.
Well done. This victory has raised our combat efficiency rating.
Oh, combat efficiency rating.
AT 7274 to the militia forces. All threats have been eliminated.
Human grunts give a different crunch.
If it's mech assault.
Hello. Hi. I'm glad we could be of service when you needed it.
Hello. Okay, I guess I'm safe here.
What is the status of the beacon?
The power is shut down.
Mech power.
Designation. Arc tool. Function. Generates power up to five megajoules.
Ooh, a whole megajoule.
Can you repair it?
We already tried.
Yeah, we already tried.
Mommy at our first convention.
Would you like to be stood on?
Are you actually good at this game?
I bet you aren't.
Yeah, I'm playing legendary difficulty.
I'm really good at this game.
Super good at this game.
Super energy boost.
What am I supposed to do?
I'm out of way without BT again.
That's it. I've had enough of this.
I've had enough of this.
I want it.
You'll be getting squished on.
They made gravity tool, Pete, literally.
Believe it or not, she still hasn't died yet.
I know, and I'm on master difficulty.
Rapid fire, ACMD.
Activate an arc tool.
Oh, I'm Baptiste, apparently.
Curious, curious.
Hello. Can I come through, please?
Yes, sir. I understand.
Open door, please.
To go this way?
Oh, OK.
I thought he was going to open a door for me.
I was like, open this?
Let me, bro.
BT, what's up with these walls?
Yes, BT.
Remind me what I'm doing again.
I'm still zero death, so.
Still zero death.
See that MLG-ness?
Oh, sorry. Sorry.
I didn't mean to kill that bot.
He was an aggressive.
That was really mean of me.
I'm sorry.
That bot didn't mean any harm.
Jeez, a whole mag?
Or am I just...
Jeez, Louise.
What does that do?
I'm already out of munitions?
Please?
Yo, got some ammo back here?
Can he be out of it?
What's this?
El Star?
Interesting, curious.
Mummy lasso run win?
What's lasso?
Oh.
You didn't see that either?
You didn't see both of those bits in combination?
Stop!
Don't laugh.
Okay.
How deep does this go?
What is this place?
It details this location that has the power grid for an IMC.
Interest in ruby kip.
Zero death.
I don't know what the number 14 is.
Well, you want to count down for ASMR or something?
What's going on?
14, 13.
16.
Oh wait, count down.
You idiot.
13, 12.
Oh.
Softball?
What do you need?
Oh.
Oh, sure.
You want me to go here, BT?
Yeah, I'm still using the jetpack because, geez.
Tool?
Arc tool required.
I'm somewhat of a tool myself.
The numbers.
What do they mean?
I don't know either.
Huh?
Are you squiddling me right now?
If that's the case,
the reef flings are forgetting a few extra zeros.
Underscored angle.
Thank you, starch power.
Perfect.
Thanks for hanging those hooking hands.
Please don't worry again.
This is the longest we...
Wait, what?
Turn it off?
Oh, I'm supposed to run against the Zamas.
Zamas.
Right, and then I'm to backtrack?
Yes, and that's with Arc tool.
Arc tool one.
With that Arc tool.
Huh?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I did not like that one.
Okay.
Hello.
Can the Arc tool hurt them?
Maybe.
You're not the Arc tool.
What did that do?
I let me get across again.
Am I going to bake it?
This one.
We'd sink cool down in progress.
Did I need to like undo it?
Because it's not going to be permanent.
No, the marvins.
You took Marvin's only purpose?
Wait, is that the name of the ball?
We Marvin?
Oh, it permanently stays up now.
Oh, I thought it was the only temporary.
Going to be a bit fucking went out.
Could you imagine the art or pain you'd be in
getting smacked in like that?
Holy shit.
Does it kill them?
No, it just disables them.
It doesn't tell them.
Okay, let's just met Irvin.
Oh, yeah, piss.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I'm falling.
I'm slipping.
And no, the good kind.
No, the good kind.
Right.
This looks right.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
Let me do that again.
I kind of said just like Tom and Jerry.
You know when Tom gets whacked and he goes, yeah.
I can't just send it like that in my head there.
Okay, let's try that one again.
Let's try that again.
Okay, one, two, three, and hi.
I'm back.
How's it going?
Thank you.
I'm glad you found it impressive.
Became a werewolf for a second.
It's when I mess it off.
I'm like, oh.
Aware squad.
Have I ever get a Halloween outfit?
I'll get a werewolf.
I'll have a little waggly tail too.
What did we do?
I kind of need to pee, but I want to keep playing.
This?
Yeah, let's hope.
Okay.
Okay, I'll be quick.
I'll be quick.
I can't remember what's inside.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Promotion.
I'm charging.
Hold on.
I'm getting fucking radiated to filth right now.
I'm charging.
Is that everything?
Oh, sorry.
I need to reload one second.
I think I'm dying.
Agh!
I don't really feel that good.
I feel like I've got radiated.
Blurgh!
Radiated.
A little bit of radiation sickness never hurt anyone.
You can't die in the room.
No.
Ooh, crazy.
Full detected.
Emergency shutdown.
Captain, the uplinked targeting module is offline.
Yes.
Not good.
I've got the IMC here on their way.
That is a reasonable assumption.
McCord, can we bypass the module?
McCord!
God, I've not had a McCoy's Crisp in so long.
The beef-flavored McCoy's Crisp.
Oh.
The situation could use us.
Sorry to go completely off topic.
The beef-flavored McCoy's Crisp.
The rigid Crisp of the cut.
The beef-flavored.
Oh.
I'm so sorry.
That was such a big side note.
Oh.
Beefy McCroy.
I need to order some unironically.
I need me.
I need me that givna.
I'm working on stuff on this one's back
and then all of a sudden my mommy screams at my ears bleed.
That's okay.
I'm mostly still here.
Lord, the volume.
I think I'm going to have to start shrooms by saying
don't listen to me loudly.
Because when I get excited, or when I get happy,
I get really, really loud.
And that's not going to hurt you.
What's the fracture?
This fracture.
Fracture was the code name of a major combat review
in operation, conducted by the militia on the planet.
Ooh.
I didn't help myself.
It sustained many casualties, but the fleet survived.
We need to hear you though.
Isn't that...
Doesn't that have the microphone placed well enough near my mouth?
Oh.
I forgot about that.
Ah.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's rather low.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
That's kind of low.
Three knots.
89 kilograms?
I thought it was like 60.
BT, you didn't tell me I was freaking doing parkour.
Jeez.
Fucking hell.
Good throw though.
Ah.
Weird.
I cannot make the distance you'll have to toss me.
Don't tell me.
Oh.
Are you spitting me right now?
I do dare.
I do defy like the last thing I hear to be you voice honestly.
Oh, no.
But then you'll get like tinnitus
and you'll get like ringing with it as well.
Crazy, JC.
That's not good.
I don't give you...
Oops.
Ow.
Sorry.
I'm...
The only thing that can hurt my...
What?
Oh.
Jeez.
Lo-
WEEE!
God.
Are these real?
Why are they fluffing?
Why do they become powder?
Hold on.
Let me reload.
Am I powdering these enemies?
Hold on.
You become mine now.
Oh.
Okay.
You're mine now.
I'm not sure this gun is my particular best friend.
Hmm.
Okay.
I don't need a rocket launcher.
I will take you.
I'll take you.
Right.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Mm-hmm.
This is what I'm talking about.
I did not...
How?
Fuck you, bitch.
No.
You're not...
What?
Oh, yeah!
I just saw you pop up the recommended channels.
Most likely because you're playing Titanfall 2
and I loved it.
Titanfall, very good game.
I've played it through once before.
I'm playing on super hard difficulty, wink, wink.
But hi, Ray, Ayanna, me.
Thank you very much for the super chat as well.
But yes, I'm enjoying it.
I just suck.
Okay, I have a better gun at least.
Oh, God, it's a three-burst fire.
Um...
I'm totally wink, wink, playing Master's difficulty right now.
Okay, I got quite the distance to go.
I can go the distance.
I have to go left to go right.
Got it.
Zero deaths, by the way.
The sucking is the best part.
When I keep playing the game,
and I don't stop even though I'm sucking, wink, wink.
I do need a pee though.
Actually, I'm waiting for Azura to, you know, pee allure allegations.
Uh...
What?
I assume that's what I'm supposed to do.
Helmet!
I see it.
If I can grab it easily, I'll go for it.
But if it's going to make me do stuff to get it, I'll pass.
Grapefruit audio when...
Clunk.
That's as far as it'll go.
Have I missed?
Fuck it.
Fuck it!
Flee!
Okay, MLG.
ML...
Call me Michael Jackson, because I'm MLG.
Wait, what?
Is that it?
And hold on.
Hold on.
Take it back.
I take my last comment back.
Let me, let me up.
Let me up.
All right, go around.
Oh, I need to go around, like, in a...
What?
What are you?
I'm supposed to go around in a circle?
Yeah.
Got a arm!
Okay, jeez.
Shit, I've already fucked it.
I've already fucked it.
Oh, I don't know how I'm making this arm.
Mummy, you're not certified for that equipment.
Go squeeze the lemon.
Yeah, sorry, I was just saying.
Azura is confirming her peeler allegation first,
and then I'll join in on the fun.
I thought it would be funny to do a denial kind of thing for a bit,
but I'm gonna start begging real quick
if you guys are like, you need to hide, jeez, and all that.
Bro, I'm not even sure I want to go over there.
Well, they're coming to me, so I've got my freaking not wish.
Yeah, they're coming to me.
Bruh!
Why are they so aggressive?
Come on.
Any munitions.
Any munitions for a soft lamb.
Master.
No, you shouldn't see anything at all.
Hey, hey.
Oh, what?
Ooh, I see a pilot.
What's this, a secret?
No.
A crate.
I can hear them, but I don't see them.
Great idea. Hydration chain.
I'm a weakling.
No, not hostile pilot.
I'm friendly.
Friendly weapon billets.
I like to share, you know what I'm saying?
Okay, I'm getting walled by a robot.
I'm fucking out.
Some things are about to take me.
Ooh.
Did you respawn when you...
Oh, no, I just killed a worker, but I'm sorry.
I'm not really a fan of this gun.
What are you?
Ooh, you're the sprayer.
I do like to be the sprayer.
What's this?
Check your HUD.
I'm checking.
Ooh, juicy.
No, I'm not trying to transmit from anywhere.
I'm a good...
I'm a good little soldier that infiltrated your facility.
I'm a well-behaved good soldier, I promise.
I'm the nicest soldier that's ever infiltrated.
Promise.
I promise.
Okay.
All the way to the right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That platform there, I see it.
He's not dead yet because I'm so rude.
She's so brave and not afraid.
Real.
Okay.
Ooh, sometimes...
Sometimes a little scared, you know?
Sometimes a little scared.
Thunderbolt?
Yeah, I'll take the fucking thunderbolt.
What the fuck?
I'll take that.
What about this?
Not those are fine.
What else is shooting?
I'll shoot these guys from afar.
Okay, BT's like in that general area.
I'm a gentle infiltrator.
I asked for permission before I thrash anuses.
That's a reference, by the way, before anyone's like,
why did you just even say that?
It's a reference.
It's a really good reference that not many people seem to know.
The projector of the dish, got it.
Move something.
I'll like to take this.
That looks heavy.
Oh my god, I once got sprung.
I thought I just heard Brian talking in there.
What is this maintenance?
What's that crap?
Come on, Ryan.
Watch some toy food.
Right, go back.
Go back.
It's fine.
It's not over.
Go back and then come forward again.
Okay, let's try that again.
Hold on.
One, two, brah.
What am I doing?
How have I done that?
Right.
Okay, one, two, three, four.
You're requesting assistance, BT.
I'm on my own doing parkour.
I need all the assistance I can get back.
I think you would give me a jump pack.
Jeez.
No, I don't need you to analyze the terrain.
I assure you, I know what to do.
I just, I'm having difficulties with gravity at the moment.
Okay, it's getting a bit difficult.
Okay, yeah, give me more of those platforms.
Not these ones.
Ah, I'm getting a cramp in my foot.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Random cramp in my foot.
Ow, ow.
Okay, okay it's subsiding.
that was that you couldn't have picked a worse time bro I need a banana give me
some potassium that there's no way I got a cramp right you're in this jump
sequence not my muscles are literally doing the fucking assassin's creed thing
where it's like your muscles remember what you're doing and the animus and
started cramping how am I supposed to get to you darling you're so far away
are you okay yeah I probably need to eat more fruit and stuff how am I to get
back to you above random helmet no what there's a zip wire I need to go upstairs
okay I'll go upstairs oh come on then BT let me help you out agree darling get
me in you don't have to tell me twice right what we're looking at infantry
shield put on lock G on the Mac oh no not these weebams shields low that's okay
can I shoot outside the shield like from behind it oh what I can that's
fantastic why did I why did it take me so long to second play through by the way
and I realized I can shoot the shield you get some okay hydration check okay
okay hydration hydration barely that was tough how are you BT oh I just dropped
no that's a no thank you are you compliment me are we in 75% in love now why
don't eat disembarked see yeah the socket for the module is at the top of his
dish a throw combined with additional climbing is required careful darling I
never said I was ready just wall at my face into the oh sorry I just a press
wrong button there my fingers were not on WASD they were on QTS oh BT you give me
a heart attack every time you do that there's nine on this mission alone big
mission big mission no god this is burst fire and you take this off Sloan more
like slain when I'm finished with you be okay one let your donor I'm hydrated are
you sure you guys it was a left and a right and I took the rest of the right
you live longer you live longer well if it doesn't require me to go hurt
myself I guess I'll go grab it helmets found gamer subs acquired like a melody
in mind that I can't see oh by the way thank you for everyone who has used the
code so far I can see how many folk have used it and you're very generous thank
you reasons I appreciate it I can't see how many and there is a potential on the
cards for oh yeah sorry sorry you don't have the gamer subs thing on oh I've
probably hidden it when I do a member stream I hate it because I'm not
advertising to you where's that game or subs no game or subs is up you're
probably just mentally ignore in it which gamer subs should I get mama
anime thighs has she be thighs on it oh I hate that a little thumbs up you're so
fucking adorable I can't handle you you're so cute thank you for saving me
you're so adorable oh my god I dare I say I think you love me 75% now yeah you're
not intercepting shit with me
oh my goodness great we don't mind if I do what my list shooting up ooh my wee
turrets them oh don't mind I've had it I love a good mech battle when I'm over
powered and they all suck well that one's already locked on some as well
hold on reloading okay they're dead
who we are Richter hello I don't know what's good I will not let you leave
alive oh yeah
each can each do it should be staying
Ike is is do it yeah it's do it yeah no that's not how you say it in German it's
like dots for dead like you're dead beauty oh my god oh do be stop oh my god
You're dead, yeah
Pots, oh close enough. I
Like heavy he comes out his mix just to flex a little as if we couldn't just snipe him right now
Oh, please do what fun in and down a client and you know, I tried to be
Yeah, guy
Oh, no wait to say sexy in German is
Hail to be sky ill for sex
I mean fuck it fuck it we mail him
I
Know you're high
To be sky ill
reflin
Yeah
Yeah, hi. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm trying gale
See you at the party
Let me jump out. What's the deal you?
Yes, I have thank you. I figured as much when you went on the platform
Can I what?
Also means super H word is it liquor thing. It's been like a thing very very y'all
Are you trying to get me to pee what's going on here?
I'm not peeing until the game's finished
It's
I
Yeah, this is true
That's me
Do you do
Yeah, see you're welcome
Why would you take us out anyway
I'm a sheen
Energy signature
Okay, there's a lot of thumbs up and in this game your balloon is gonna be bad at P now
Let's keep on
No one is separating. That's exactly she's made back off exactly
child by fire
And more thumbs and up what it was is a very thumbs up kind of game
But
Weapons, huh
Oh
Please applause
They said oh no, that's drumroll. Sorry wait, please applause. They said Titan fall prepare for Titan fall
Sorry, it's put drumroll on by accident. Oh
We're taking down this moment wall
I
What am I today
Why would you change my load out
Am I even helping I hope
Okay, let's go. Let's go. Let's go
No luck I might be able to get one. It's not bad. It is buddy over here. Oh
Yeah, you got like so much quicker I
Don't even notice that enemy you're so small. I didn't even see you
Now you guys don't see that one
Oh, this is sad I do love. Oh, I love a good Mac battle when you're OP
I
Love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. I love it. Oh
I'm trying I'm trying let me appreciate the gameplay though. Oh
Okay, we're going we're going we're going we're here
Unless we're stuck
We suck until
I'm trying
I guess I
Am I not to go here am I gonna win?
Or is it just more fighting for a bit more? Sorry
Oh, of course it opens
Legion more like Lee gone
Oh gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
Cheater
Only I'm a load shield, you know the rules
Let's get out of here
Did you try and play with them? Oh, did you not hear the applause? Oh
It may have been those two loads
I'm ready to see chains up ahead. Sorry guys. Whoa
Think we'll get rid of you first
So it was very close combat. Oh
I'm with you wasn't I not just to be freaking taken off a BT like a moment ago. Can I crush them? Oh
Yeah, I can you're friendly
I'm trying
I
Do scorchers
I don't really want to get in trouble because they have that aimed-down sight thing in mobile
But that goes around. I don't know. I
Wonder if they can kill themselves with their own damage
Oh
Gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous. Sorry. I know I'm kind of repeating myself. I just I'm loving this. I'm just loving the
Just going for it. Um
I'm one happy being right now replaying this game
BT fees a perfect example of why I love the odd sales of makes and not just this other robot that have their own character
Yeah, I agree with that
This squish sound effect, yeah, I'm gonna be I'm not really sure what a squish
It's Hawkins still a thing
You mean like Stephen Hawking no he passed away
You wanted to go to the island
Sorry, I don't know what Hawkins is
Where right? You're so much faster than me
I'm coming. Oh, bro. I'm like a mile away across the map
You have to give me some more time
No, the Molly player make it. Oh, sorry
I
Was like, I'm not got a clue, but you don't have a darling. Sorry. I'm all got a clue real voice reveal
Yeah, I am not really a robot. I
Like
But I am truly I am a I
Made in made in the government lab
Can't do it and think at the same time. I keep freaking like going from one to the other
I
Says a Titan was locked on to me there a monk. Oh fuck it
Can can the aim please
More like can I aim that chance of that clearly
It can only be one tone on this map and ain't you buddy
Enemies locking someone's locked on to me
Oh, who's someone's locking on to me that's right next to me
Ah, I don't want BT to get hurt
Right look faster
I read that's ten a reef for me now only one tone, you know how it goes
Ah, you got me
See even the enemies are using tone, you know, it's the best Mac
Oh
My god allies, please don't get in my way
We're gonna get my way at least it like but the other way Tom stop it
Only I get to use shield see only me not you
Oh
I didn't realize that was an enemy I'm getting confused cuz the allies right there
Mummy's AI ignore all other problems ignore all other problems make the reef links, thank oh
I'm fucking going
Inc XC loaded
What do you need darling you look horny I can fix that
You look like an honest hard-working
What do you need baby anything for you I don't judge
I'm here to fulfill your every fantasy
What's that you just like when girls play video games god damn I've got you in a choke hold
Big feet big feet
Possibly yeah, oh, these are friendly. Sorry I
Could not be a ground imagine being a ground force going against the I
Completely missed the lock on but hey, oh
I'm missing everything on you
I love that make a rain hellfire, baby
Can you actually lose this mission
Our dialogue is the same they're taking off they're taking off they're taking off okay, we get it. They're taking off
I'm really I'm trying. I know it's hard to believe but I am trying
We have no other option do we actually not are you just saying that
I'm going I'm going
I
Waited up at that most
It's pre-determined. Okay, good. I was like cuz she keeps saying I'm like
Come on. Oh, no, please don't throw me. I just look I think I think I get thrown
Okay
We were like, oh, no, we were just four seconds too slow. Thank you
Eat the coffee
Hold on any a real odd
I
Didn't do anything that I was even paying attention go pee. I'm we about to finish isn't this it
A flying mix done does that have some mobility?
It's like another now there's a little bit more
I
Do love, okay. Oh
My fucking ankles
Are you okay?
What do we do
The Malta you're sending me a Malta. I don't know how to speak Italian
You can do this
Just like before
No, no, no, no, no do the math you do the math. I trust you just you do it
Don't say it out loud. Don't say what the percentages don't say it out loud
Am I gonna make it I'm not even I
I
Thought you put me on that
No, that's fine understandable how nice there was like this platform here lose a helmet
Tame it wait up to tame it
I
Said wait, I've got to pull away me the only
Whoa
only
But who's driving this buzz?
No, seriously, who's driving the ship cuz something's not going on
Sometimes not right in the ship and you guys are worried about me
Please be so for real go hide in a bunker or something at least let me know no no no no no no no
Q yeah killed it
No, they're so freaking creepy stop it
Why did my gun just change was I not just on a
Oh
Then you want a sniper
Our grenades the thing in this game sometimes
Let's shift the toggles and me up me up me up me up me up
Give me the frickin shirt. No, what don't pick up a random pistol
I think go view little fucking shit he activated the robots
Right controversial is this one of the ones where I can skipity boo
Very controversial, but I'm out of ammo
I'm out of ammo and I'm out of options unless someone wants to drop me a gun right now. I'm off
See you later alligator in a whale crocodile. I have ne ammo Nina and give me your get damn gun
Give me the fucking thing
I'm stuck shit. So didn't no stop giving
Stop giving me these fucking things
What is this stop it stop it oh
My god, I need to go back and get the other guns
Stop giving me mastiffs. I'm not using a sniper
I refuse I bet you have ammo. Oh
Okay, maybe I'm using a fucking sniper. Oh, I got spitfire ammo
Is that why they want me a fucking have a mastiff so bad I
Don't see him wait, what's my objective?
I
Interact with it or just clear it like that
Yeah, right, okay, okay? See this is what happens when you there's anyone on it
There's anyone on it
What my missing there's something my brains something's not clicking
clear all
The broadside gun flat forms so kill
Kill
Okay, right. Okay. Okay again. Just stand I understand
The broadside of a barn, okay, that was a checkpoint and let me guess go to the end one
What's my check point I
Mean I can see more of the map over there. Oh
Where were you guys a few minutes ago did they just
Get deployed in handshake. Yeah, good cover fire. Yeah, it's fucking shit. I never got one kill
You never go one kill
It's never boring
Okay
Okay, okay
Okay, time to shine
Time to fuck. How are you all lined up?
And this is why the spitfire is the best gun in the game because you can actually get kills without having to swap constantly
Actually, maybe we will play Call of Duty 6 together. I'm not I'm not gonna lie. I think I'd actually really enjoy that
I'm enjoying the
Maybe not zoom in so much. Sorry. Yeah, let's move. Yeah
I got you. Yeah, I think maybe I don't know we might give cod sick. Is it there's a bit of free right now. I
Might give a swatch offline see how I feel
I
Okay, good. Good. I'm glad it's up take control of the bridge
You could try to tank for two multiplayer it's still up right now
I'll need to play off lane. I don't know if it's safe or not
I'm ready
I
Not bad then go spitfire ammo. Yeah, no, they all had pistols. Yeah, sure
Oh, I thought maybe he's gonna like open up and hack it again
Copy that
I'm trying to get there. God. I suck at driving. I don't remember getting my fucking license from a nice
As a can of getting behind it
I'm not too high. I can't tell can someone give me like a 3d perspective right now to high good Lord, right?
I'll pull back the fucking stick already if someone else doesn't take over everyone's got fucking son to see
Hi, oh careful
Yes, please
We lost your life Lord. Oh, no, there's a fight here
Time to pay
There is nowhere to run
No, we're not what a vocal fry
Right, that's it. That's it. This game's getting put in the bin stop swapping when I don't want you to
Oh
You're fucking cheating
I'll enolize you after this fight don't think I'll enolize you after this fight president the particle wall
Ah
He's tethered me we fucking bam pop give me the fucking heel
He's got me good honestly use a nasty piece of work
It seems like if I get a hit on him well, whoa, whoa, no no no no no no no no no no no no we're not doing that
We're not doing that
I'll shoot you in the air. I'll I fucking 360 right now. Hold on. Let me reload and I'll 360
Holy crap. He's hot. He's beating my ass
Jeez that was not an easy thing
Thank you Oregon a new feature quad 6 is open make chap between players if I take him as a human
Yeah, that's why I want to play it so I can grab you and I can be like hey there's a race on how you let me
Wisp in your ear. I got a little pistol
Is your piss that pistol are you just happy to see me
We're gonna go to the edge. I think
Imagined rather than suddenly here's I'm sorry mommy. I'm about to ink. Oh my god. Wait you'd grab me in game
That'd be how you talk
Okay, I think it's time. Yep, let's go
Thank you typical nation if I went back to multiplayer you get me your ass whipped. I'm not sure
Oh
Wait, what did we not just kill them?
Am I losing it
Oh shit, oh my god BT. You need to stay on this fucking thing
Yeah, fuck you bitch
Holy fuck, are you okay BT?
I give me a thumbs up. It's fucking armless careful
You're on fire
To do what
Okay, okay, okay, okay got it got it got it got it got it got it got it don't have to tell me twice
Don't have to tell me twice. I'll figure it out. I'll figure it out
Let's get off figure out. Don't worry BT. BT is fine. It's fine
We're trying we're doing it. We're doing it. We're getting there right everyone's using evac pods good
We don't have to fight. We don't have to fight
Yeah, what do you mean BT? Oh
My god, at least he has an arm to do that
Shit
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, pick me up pick me up. Let's get it. Let's get it. Let's get it
Can I touch it with my hands without you know exploding or something?
Oh
I'm trying it's heavy. Okay, it's rejecting
Coming
There's no way I was supposed to serve
I
Hate this I
Hate this
No, I'm not gonna cry. I've already played the game before I'm not gonna cry. I'm your baby. I
I can't handle when games randomly do that. It's supposed to be I'm sure
I fucking hate when they do that
I'm tearing up. I'm not gonna cry. I refuse to cry. I cry all the time
Protects on it. No, don't you make me cry even more if I think of it as you
Okay, maybe I'm crying a little
This is not no, I don't have snog
Totally none of you wait my eyes right now because I can't see the screen
Oh
Be too open the hatch when this guy's dead. Yeah, fuck
Still trying to be here
I have a lot of dodge riding on this contract my friend
So tell your titan if he doesn't open up
I will shoot you in the face. I didn't like that, buddy
I
Be TV enough five heads actually, you're smarter than me
Cooper trust me those tears for you
Received encrypted methods
That's the problem with teams if you don't win together
Oh
Can I get up? Oh
Holy shit, here's a little look
Thank you typical nation
I don't believe in torture, but the gloves are off
The gloves are off cuz what the fuck was that
That's only the reason to wait the tears come here right now
Pick them up pick them up pick them up pick them up pick him up pick him up. Yes
Yes, he's he's he's he's he's
You're gonna
Oh
Beauty this is you buddy all your ones and zeros are inside here
God even till the very end the mix are made to protect the pilot
Even till the very end
There is of course
There you are my baby right I've got the precious cargo
Survive where am I to go?
I've got you that's all that matters. That's literally all that matters in this game. Oh
Oh
My game just a holy shit you give me aim ball. Oh
My gosh, I forgot oh
My I'm a lethal weapon
You can do that for me
Holy shit, that's so cool
That is so cool
It's not over until it's over oh
My gosh, I'm a fucking lethal weapon when I have you oh
Oh goodness me
I'm going I'm going I'm going
I am the boots on the ground and there's not much ground for my boots to be on fuck
Realist right get the story
Yeah, let's try that again
No, I did it again for fuck's sake. I don't expect to touch the seed and then I touch it and then all the momentum gets lost
It's cuz I keep actually touching the freaking say
But I don't mean to and then I hit it when it's far. Yeah, like it just
It's doing it right there
Okay, oh
My god, you're so pee
Oh
Let's keep her going
My titan they said it
Wait, you're empty
Oh, you got BT back already you're empty
Are you mine?
Hello Jack oh
Hi daddy
How do you feel
Oh, yeah
It's time to complete our mission
From refland to daddy, I don't know why it feels very daddy like you being a make for me is very
Sorry, sorry, I know I know I know you something different. I know
Deeper, so our look
Ah and damn things are here. I thought I was supposed to back up
You guys are gonna lock a bit better. Okay. Thank you. I need a wee bit help
End of the lane. Yeah for you
My ultimate's ready
I'm moving I'm moving I'm getting a move on whoa
Oh
My gosh, do you have any freaking pilots we destroy
What a situation representative a sit rap the situation
Coming in I'm coming in
Oh, that's a lot of enemies got a lot of enemies
For what how many I think we're gonna
I'm trying
This
I'm
Whoa, whoa, whoa, what was that laser sight?
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying to evade but I ain't good like at the games like these
All of them done
Yeah
The scorcher you can burn through my shield, I'm pretty sure
Where did it go okay good good good good good good good good good you can drop you do get a gum drops
I missed I'm missing. Sorry. I'm missing ignore me. I'm missing
Yes, oh god, bye
Yeah, that's not as I ain't got nothing more to offer and other than insta fucking death
Yeah, I regret him seeing the afterlife buddy
Sucks to suck sucks to not have 90% efficiency with your Mac sucks to suck
Sucks to suck buddy because it's not me
You pick the wrong team to get a paycheck from
Hold on let me reload
Set rate for short for situation report
It's a small world we're burning sorry no sorry literally sorry nothing to do with me if you slug
Targeting
Lurking in the shadow. Oh, those are friendly boats. I'm sorry
Yeah, lots of heels. Let's fucking go. Oh, okay. Sorry. Hold on. Excuse me. We'll say try to walk through the glass
It's
My forces will take over general murder. We're like general shite bag
Yes, Sloan, it's ogre actually ogre
Remember that time you killed BT knees back. Yeah, this time it's actually gonna be a fair fucking fight you slag
Mmm, I'm gonna try and take out the weird ones and then use my ultimate on her
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Oh, oh, oh, oh, stop with that, please
Are you fucking see what was that? How does she your ultimate in five seconds bugger my ultimate in half an hour? Oh
My god, you got me stop. Don't do it again. I'm getting scared
What do you mean get him whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's cheating
You call in reinforcements, but then you get to it. I would like to call upon the refunds to fucking come be my stand-in
I'm not really
Okay, I have my ultimate. I'm gonna save it for her. I'm saving my ultimate for her suit because I'm no one to get in trouble
I
Seem to be able to hit from here
Yeah, you're the one who's shate your shate with a capital eight
Let's get rid of him in the background to get a farm my ultimate. Ow, how did that hurt me?
No, no, no, not again not with a laser
Nothing personal, buddy
Can you kill him dad my ultimate? No, I don't
Hello
Oh fuck off she disappears just as a drop that you slag
Yeah, we slag yeah, oh
Come on come on
Hold on hold on hold on hold on what's that something's not going the way I want it to
What do you mean let's do this you've been calling in reinforcements the entire freaking school like what do you mean?
I let us do this. No, you're just being cheesy to do in the whole effing fight. I
I'm not walking away that easy. It's you that's been a weirdo with this laser beam. I can't even get out of the way
Please get her please please fuck you bitch
How how what I do I don't know this
BT BT. Oh
Spammy
I'm filling it. I'm filling it. Can we grab his head real quick?
I
See
Ah
I'm not going to kill you. I don't work for free
But you don't get to kill me either
Yeah, you weren't the same
I
About problem order should have put it in my contract. I've got other people with money to see
I mean to be honest, that's kind of funny
He's gonna throw me off the ship
Okay, W
Oh
Dear
Can I not just take his we head with me like come on the game just showed me I can take his head
I
Don't I'm not going anywhere
Protect pilot
Oh
Wait, did he actually die I've forgotten the end and I'm starting to cry again. Wait, is he dead?
I can't remember if he's alive or not
Wait, am I being dumb is he actually dead or am I crying for no reason? What was I supposed to land on?
Wait, but we never grabbed his core is he gone
Not him sending me to do parkour is the last mission as well. Well, is it and I
Can't see the screen properly
I'm fucking going I'm jumping
Holy fuck
I
Where I have tears dripping down my face right now, I can't remember if BT's with me or not, but he jumped in the corner
Holy shit, we just destroyed that plan
And
BT you caused a lot of discharge I can't remember
Is this not like where they give you a little wink or something like at the industry where it flashes of it
Destruction of typhoon save the planet harmony
Militia calls this planet their headquarters
millions of others call it home waiting for B. E. Pope open the corner like
I genuinely can't remember the end
I don't know what that'll feel like to get a sign a new type
Kind of like the old one
This is pilot Jack Cooper signing off
Hmm
Did they actually kill fucking BT
Is that what we look like
I
Watch the credit
That's what you look like underneath the helmet reflin
I
Say thanks to the dev team, but I'm a bit distraught right now
There's no way they killed BT after that like there's actually nearly because why would you do that?
I must start writing emails to the CEO
Okay, but props to the dev team for putting like a congratulations like you finished the mission type thing but
Does it actually feel like it
And yeah about Titanfall 3
They be healing you a hero though
It is McCree
Who voices BT
Glen Stein beum
So German name or Stein bomb
Soldier 76. Oh really?
Weirdly the guys only voice just been to you
Sometimes the development team accidentally become the voice actors it's um it's happened before
It'll happen again
And
I'm like 99% sure that's who Anna is from overwatch
They were the person responsible for hiring was looking for
Aim someone to fit Anna's makeup and it happened to be the hiring person for Anna and they were like have it
We just use you
Although it could be wrong, but I'm like 99% sure
Yeah, Donkey Kong's VA is one of the deaths from rare. Yeah
Daddy favorite
Yeah, like a lot of background or in general voice lines in that or it can be done by the dev teams
Cuz obviously it's quite an exciting opportunity
Imagine like being like Jared Bell from like hey, can you scream in a mic for like death sounds in the background? Sure?
Most of the voice cast and Hades as members of the team. Yeah. Yeah
Yuri and my agency
What a cool name Matthew will fuck sake couldn't get a cooler name than that. Could you I wish your name mr. Wolf
It's spider-man. Oh was it did I miss it Peter Parker?
I
Imagine getting asked the morning grunt to finalize the pro
I mean you need death sounds you need like that. Oh, I'm under fire cover fire
Strongly we need five more hours and what I mean hurt sound effects. I think I said that I listened to a panel
of voice actors in a game and someone asked they were like
how do you differentiate between a
Victual moon and like being in pain and the voice actors was literally like you can't
Because it depends on how you take it when you hear it and
Type thing it's not really
You know the diff you can always take it out of context
You know what I mean like you know make a sound because I could pretend to get stabbed and I'll be ah
But like, you know you could take it
The other way instead if I do that, you know, it depends how you
I'm accidentally just walking the context is the main thing that differentiates that mmm
And they get the good stuff getting stabbed and I'm sure about that
The human mind is a beautiful thing
So much stronger for so much content
How do you take it mummy?
Hmm
Why couldn't it be both them well if you hired for a job to make hurt sound effects
Then I
Don't think they're gonna want it to sound a bit too
That pop she doesn't take she give
If I want to take
I take
If I want to move
If I want you to die
you die
That's an assassin's green brotherhood quote
Sounds a bit too posh for me
What cute song for a dramatic ending yeah, the internet has been placing grunts of pain zones for the R34 yeah
Can he deny that I've watched my fair share overwatch and I'm like, huh, that's a literally in-game son
Mortal Kombat has good pain zones, but not good enough
Man, I can't wait to see how the story continues in time for three oh
How about you do you ever think you send late you getting hurt by mistake?
I've definitely done more gruntier audios
Gruntier audios seem to be well received like received better than like more lovey-dovey, I guess
Ring fit noises for example
I think the devs don't know their target audience of that's a concern heavy breathing from Sprint and heavy breathing from
Refland's like the grunting confirmed. Yes, I
Was them using my alternative Twitter posts to see like what got the most popular in terms of likes to show me a
preference
I'll need to check out what the results are cuz I posted it yesterday
I don't know what's been going on because I've not got Twitter on
I've got regularly
Could you have calibrated to my helmet?
So I don't need to be sad okay, I don't need to be sad
That's Morse code, but what is remember BT uploaded himself into your helmet and that one mission
No, I don't remember
What is it hold on?
Titan fall to what is the Morse code in helmet?
I think what should we look up right now?
It says Jack question mark at the end of the credits you get a short cut scene of Jack's helmet
Sitting the visor lights up blue and a few short flashes flashes before the visor goes great and the screen fades out
These flashes however spell the spell this one word message in Morse code Jack question mark
He's waiting on me I
Guess cuz he can't see so he just has the Morse code fucking flash bang me
I
Just refresh marshmallow someone sent me the lyrics to butterfly. Where's my samurai?
I've been searching for a man all across Japan just to find to find my samurai
Someone who is strong, but still a little shy. Yes. I need I need my samurai
I
Have you little butterfly green black and blue make the colors in this guy. Oh, that's such a cute song
Mmm, well, we did it. I didn't expect to blast through the campaign
I mean, I guess because I knew what sections could have been ignored
and
Yeah, cuz
Because I could
Because I knew which sections weren't actually having to be fulfilled
It's more to go to reject BT may be alive out in space at his core
But it's just a theory a game theory literally. No, don't say that to me
We fun. I know he's alive in my helmet and I'm gonna upload on it's gonna take us gonna take a hot second to transfer him into a core
But he's in there. Okay, I
Want to see if she can do it. I'm a funny bear. I'm a funny bear. Yes. I'm a gummy bear
I'm a moving smoothing funny oney gummy bear. Wow
What would a bing bing? Uh-uh, what would a bing bing?
Six hours of mummae. I guess because I did that membership
I forgot about that. I'm never done a stream it to him again. That's all I'm saying
And
All right, well, we did a marshmallow reading is embers coming on today are
Sheep's up the sheepsters up. No, she be she be did
She did a pop-up, but is she doing a stream stream?
No, she's not there
What about
Oh, wait
She's done a collab with emmy Vivian and soul proud
I'm no like to say it, but yeah, I'm glad I'm glad
That's funny that's funny, I know who this girl
If you know, you know, if you don't know that's perfectly okay, not to know you're not missing out on anything later
Okay, we were redirected sheepsters in around ten minutes time
Did you sleep well? I got five hours
Cheeky five hours. Yeah
Mm-hmm
Did you sleep well five hours?
Should we read then? Yes
I will redirect at the start of her stream because I don't want to distract from the fact she's doing a collab and
Like I was watching Mercy's collab yesterday on my dad
my dad see of my dad and I
Just look noticed the least up. Yeah, I had to put you down there because it looks I couldn't really have you know
Like on my face and I didn't want to I thought it was six hours. I went to bed
So I went to bed at 4 p.m. But I couldn't sleep so I got back up again and leaked my schedule for the month
Oh, I was like, hmm. What can I do? I'll just leave my schedule. Why not and?
And then I was like listen to music I listen to my doomer music
I've been listening to like the blade runner playlist where it's like you can't fix that
One of the titles of one of them and a lot of dr. Kitty and stuff. I seem to have really sad errors
I'm not like greeting to myself right now. I just need to be like really moody at night. Um
Not the worst thing someone's leaked why is the leash
Reaffling frowning that'd be a big issue. You're not frowning. I think you're just like you don't know what to do next
As we are
I'm not listening up. It's illegal illegal. I'm not looking at
And
You look you look like a reef one I
Can ink that I can milk that you look like a reef line
Let me milk you
You're like a good honest reef one the black up six beta. How is it free and how long is it up?
Because I would need to do a pop-up stream for it. I don't even know what my agendination is this week
And I'm unfortunately have to go to the dentist boo
Boo, I'm getting my teeth cleaned. Oh tomorrow's Pikmin. I don't know how long Pikmin is
Everyone everyone said Pikmin this Pikmin that how about you?
Pick up a pickaxe and play Minecraft with me. It's free for game pass user
You still have one hold I have one day right now. I'm not fucking timing it like that if I've got one day
No, you look our word. Let me show you that was I didn't say that this stream
Mmm the original
How about you pick me pick men have it I pick you instead. Oh, you're so these are so sweet hearts
And the door of all strong is a pick me is a pick men pick me in
Tomorrow's Pikmin, then I've got watching you. I need to make my chest account. I don't know what to name it
strongy more like
The night because it's my favorite little pawn piece board thingy my barber, please don't read out loud
No
You're allowed to being chill. I'm not a jealous streamer. I promise just enjoy yourself that one
Hi strongy, what color if applicable? Oh, I've got black today going with the go theme. Love you
You silly sausage. I love you to you refling sausage
You still reflin reflin we fling me fling
P fling
P and reflin's mouth call him a P fling. Sorry
We actually have a clore today. Yes, unfortunately, I have to
Not fair
Not really a funny mouth for me today
So my brain's not working for some reason just want to say I love you so much and you bring me so much joy
Yeah, bring you joy ten nine eight seven
No, don't entertain that I love you too. Don't
I'm so sick of this brain worms this brain worms that how about we fuck each other's brains are not thinking anymore. Oh
Refling said
Um
Are you squidding me right now?
Instead of griping let's call it struggle snuggles. Oh, I kind of like that
Oh
I came to like that
Do you want some struggle snuggles from mommy come on we fling come here
Don't forget to try
That's really bad. This is why you can't encourage me. Thank you the beauty lord, but you can't encourage me. I
Said one an hour ago may got filtered. I don't I've got the lyrics. I've got a Pokemon
I
Beloved I just remembered what I was gonna say to you don't feel bad about singing after dark on stream yesterday
My heart may explode from it, but it's purely a happiness and love love you strong a water in my eyes writing that by the way
All right, I'll need to stop singing that bro. I'll need on the knock off
um
Uh, please don't read this thing
I have read and understood. Thank you
Okay, I'm analizing I'm analizing. Okay, I understand
Oh my god, fellow feature retainful two lover I've already wrapped up. I'm so sorry
I've already wrapped it up. Shebe's got a vod out though. My gen mate. She'd be caught in bum. She's link in the description below
Uh, she played it for the first time. So if you want to see it through a new player's eyes
I definitely recommend her vod my void. I just skipped the parts that I know I can skip because it's the second time
No, I didn't cry. You can't prove it
I I didn't cry twice playing this game even though I played it a year ago
You never said the rating for titanfall
Um 100 out of 100 because bt is alive if bt genuinely fucking dies it becomes zero
It becomes zero
Oh, hold on. It's another one. I'm not supposed to read out loud. There's a lot of things I'm not supposed to read out loud
I
I'm sorry for worrying
It's okay
Sorry, I'm not very smart. I think that's the problem. I'm not very smart
I just tried my best. Don't sorry
I laid laner running for sure. I'm not crying. I got a bug in my a bug
Stony so brave and definitely can from her eyes all over the place
I didn't like completely forgot all the sections. I forgot that last segment
I was like, wait, you can't do that to me. What the fuck?
I've been here since day one
You can't do this to me
I hate someone replied to the twitter post. You got four days off in a month
No, I had to censor what I'm doing on that day because it's gonna leak some stuff
No, that's funny
Um
That's funny. Yes, there's a left or dead stream snipe comment
I'm coming up
You gonna let me
Um
Yeah
Who's cutting onions? I'm not crying you are
Oh gee modern warfare to play through ghost death only
I was thinking about doing overwatch to
It overwatched to modern warfare to um campaign at some point. I'd probably spread it out a bit because we've been
Um very rooty mc2e shooty
babooty, um
And I'm trying to get like a good mix of stuff, but I don't know if I'm managing to do it
I'm like trying to make it so it's not like the same category every single day
I'm trying to like, you know, we do a bit of blast from the past. We do a bit of the future. We do a bit of theme
Thank you for all the effort and hard work you put into stream everything about you make me happy. You're a blessing
I'm a blessing on your life
Oh
That goes like this the fourth the fifth
Um
I think what else are we doing this week?
We're doing pikmin and then ismar and then we're doing we're watching an anime. I'm proving that I'm a weeb. We're watching vivi
fluoride ice
Wait isn't fluoride what's in toothpaste? Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute vivi flu
Fluoride ice song. What a name. What does it even mean? No one's got a clue
I've got castle crashers collab. I've got ring fit and shit. Okay, and then elden ring stream snipe
So it's just pure stream snipe
Uh, I've got three days of elden ring in a row so I can technically leak like tomorrow the day after the week
um
but yeah
It's also in the fresh water supply
Mommy you better ready the tissues though. No, don't make me put my guard up because we'll have another edith finch moment
Uh, I played edith finch. It was like this game. It was like a two-hour story game
It was just kind of like a walk simulator story time thing
And I got warned that it was really sad
And because it was because I got warned my like guard was up the entire time
And I was like, yeah
So don't warn me about it. Don't give me a warning. Let me go and blind. Okay. Let me go and blind
um
Let me have no clue what's going on. We'll find out on that day how I feel
Um, yeah, I would say it's actually rather tame this week. I'd say
the weeb watch along
is probably
Is it bad to say that I'm like
It would be my like not prepared stream. Obviously. I'm really biased because I get to play elden ring with you
Like any game I get to play with you. I'm like stream is 10 out of 10. I don't care
Um, uh, let me not be clear. Let me not be transparent
Game to try is before your eyes. We're just going to send you only heartbreaking enemies. You better not
so mommy like surprises
Say nothing at all even saying something is a spoiler is a spoiler
How about the dragon cancer game? What does that mean?
Skyrim
Dragon can't skyrim
Skyrim's good
She be gone live. Okay
redirect momentum
Plop plop plop get love get love get love. No, you get love
You do your best to make us happy. That's what matters. Love me more me simple. Hey, that's my lane. Love me briefly and simple
aim
You're an edge runner watch along. I don't think my heart can take that
Dragon cancer is sick hero. I think
A dragon cancer is an actual game name. Oh
Do no don't let her play that dragon cancel edge on air
Yeah, where's the poll on twitter? I can't find either. There's no poll on twitter
You should try death road to canada. It's a fun little game
Uh
Right we're i'm not gonna stall because I don't want to redirect in the middle of she v's um play in the game
So, uh, it's actually been short. I thought we were gonna get a good five hours
But I'm afraid I may have girl bossed a little too hard. Um, I love you lots
I'm sorry. It was a bit shorter today than I anticipated tomorrow's Pikmin. I have no idea how long it's going to take me to go through
um, I
Played it in the hospital as a child. Um, and I don't remember anything
Of it. I never finished it. Okay
right, I'm a redirect into sheberton, um, and
Then I will
Far yes, I will find
yes
Um, you say hi sheebie and emmers, of course emmers is up as well. I'm playing with a vivian and so
Um, love you lots. I'll see you tomorrow. Sorry. It's been so short. Um
Just like me. Uh, no
Is there oh the png isn't perfect on
I'll need to swap you out for tinfoil hat. I just realized it's putting a wee line on my face. Thank you
Oh, hold on a minute. Hold on a minute
How many kisses how many missions are there and how many loadouts are there in this game?
I think there's like eight loadouts. So you get eight kisses one
three
one
five
Next
My name eight eight loadouts. I think how many deaths zero obviously
I actually don't know how many times I died to gravity, but it was all gravity literally gravity was my biggest issue
Right, please enjoy shebie and emmy and vivian and so
And I'll talk to you goofy goobers tomorrow for some Pikmin and you're gonna have to carry me through because I have no
clue what's about to happen. Okay
See tomorrow here, bye-bye